THE JOINT SUBCOMMITTEE ON RULES
SO SEXUAL HARASSMENT PREVENTION
AND RESPONSE THE SUIT THAT I
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT NUMBER
HEARING THIS IS AT THIS MOMENT
NUMBER FIVE.
AND WE HAVE BEEN DOING A VERY.
A COMPREHENSIVE DEEP DIVE INTO
THE ISSUES SURROUNDING SEXUAL
HARASSMENT ALL WITHIN AIMED
TOWARDS REBUILDING OUR CURRENT
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES AND
TRAINING FROM THE GROUND UP. AND
MAKING SOMETHING THAT WILL BE
PROTECTIVE OF OUR CAPITAL
COMMUNITY AND ALSO I HOPE A
MODEL FOR. OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY A BASED ON
THE INFORMATION THAT WE'VE BEEN
GETTING FROM. OUR EXPERTS FROM
ALL AROUND THE COUNTRY IN AND
CERTAINLY FROM HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. TODAY'S HEARING IS
ABOUT OUR PREVENTION AND
TRAINING. AND FOR THIS HEARING
OUR VICE CHAIR SENATOR HOLLY
MITCHELL OF WAS THE LEAD AND I'M
GOING TO TURN TO HER TO MAKE
WHATEVER INTRODUCTION SHE WOULD
LIKE.
TO THIS TOPIC.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM CHAIR YES THIS IS HEARING
NUMBER FIVE AND BECAUSE I'M
ANAL.
WE'VE HEARD SO FAR UP TO THIS
POINT FROM TWENTY ONE WITNESSES
IF YOU SAID FROM ACROSS THE
COUNTRY THE STATE AND HAVE SPENT
OVER TWELVE HOURS. JUST IN
HEARING THAT DOESN'T COUNT ALL
OF THE TIME WE'VE SPENT PLANNING
AND AND STAFF HAVE SPENT.
AUTUMN COLD MEAN THE COUNTRY
LOOKING FOR EXPERTS IN YOUR
RESPECTIVE FIELDS TO COMMON
EDUCATE US AND SO WE'VE WE HAVE
INVESTED GOOD TIME. ON AND WILL
CONTINUE TO DO SO THIS IS
HEARING NUMBER FIVE.
IN TERMS OF KIND OF OUR
EXPECTATIONS AROUND PROCESS AND
STRUCTURE IT WAS OUR PLAN THAT
THE NEXT.
AND FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE LEAST
TENTATIVELY FINAL HEARING WOULD
GIVE US THE OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR
THE RESULTS OF THE CLIMATE
SURVEY.
UNFORTUNATELY WE BOTH LEARNED
YESTERDAY THAT REALLY THE
CONTRACTING PEACE SO IT'S REALLY
ADMINISTRATIVE. OF THE CLIMATE
SURVEY HAS BEEN DELAYED UNTIL
THE CLIMATE SURVEY HASN'T
STARTED. TO OUR UTTER DISMAY A
WE ARE FOLLOWING UP TO JUST KIND
OF MONITOR THAT PROCESS WE'RE
GONNA. I LOOK FOR TO THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SIT DOWN AND JUST
HAD A CONVERSATION ALMOST THE
VENDOR THAT'S BEEN SELECTED
BEFORE THE THE SURVEY.
IS EXECUTED AND SO WE CAN'T SAY
AT THIS POINT WHEN THE NEXT
HEARING WILL BE. BECAUSE THE
COMMITMENT IS TO.
THE VOTE THAT HEARING TO HEARING
THE RESULTS OF THE CLIMATE
SURVEY SOME I THINK IT'S SAFE
DISABILITY AFTER SPRING RECESS.
THAT IS NOT OUR DESIRE NOR WAS
IT KIND OF OUR VISION AND PLAN.
BUT APPARENTLY THE CONTRACTING
PROCESS ON TOOK MUCH LONGER THAN
I CERTAINLY ANTICIPATED OR THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAIRWOMAN SO I
JUST WANT TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TO KIND OF KNOW. WHERE WE WERE
AND THE GENERAL PUBLIC IN TERMS
OF? EXPECTED NEXT STEPS.
WITH THAT THANK YOU YEAH I JUST
TO CLARIFY I'M THAT WILL BE OUR
LAST HEARING TO DELVE INTO THESE
ISSUES AND WHAT WE WILL ALSO BE
GIVING DIRECTION TO STAFF AND
COMING BACK AT SOME POINT
WHETHER IT'S IN THIS HEARING OR
IN THE JOINT CHOI GENERAL RULES
COMMITTEE.
TO PRESENT THE NEW POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES REGARDING THE
RECOMMENDATIONS YEAH POOR FOR
ADOPTION HOPEFULLY I KNOW YOU
KNOW IT AND THAT'S WHERE THE
PUBLIC CAN ALSO I'M GIVE INPUT
AND.
I WILL FEEL MENTION THIS AGAIN
AT THE END BUT BECAUSE OF THE.
WHEN THE CLIMATE SURVEY STARTS
THIS WILL BE I'D ON OPPORTUNITY
FOR ALL MEMBERS OF STAFF TO. I'M
PARTICIPATE IN THE CLIMATE
SURVEY AND I HOPE THAT EVERYBODY
DOES PARTICIPATE BECAUSE WE WANT
TO HEAR. YOUR THOUGHTS AND AND
THAT'S NOT THE ONLY WAY TO GIVE
INPUT WE DO HAVE OUR SUGGESTION
BOX WE HAVE WAYS THROUGH THE
INTERNET TO.
AWAY AND OF COURSE WE DO A
PUBLIC A COMMENT AT EVERYONE OF
THESE HEARINGS SO ON THIS IS
THAT YOU KNOW IF YOU'VE BEEN
THINKING ABOUT GIVING US SOME
INFORMATION OR GIVING US YOUR
SUGGESTIONS. THIS IS THE TIME TO
START YOU KNOW MAKING SURE THAT
YOU DO THAT BEFORE WE COME BACK
WITH OUR FINAL RECOMMENDATIONS
AND DIRECTIONS FOR THE NEW
POLICIES. WITHOUT ALSO IF ANY OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE
COMMENTS BEFORE WE BEGIN.
I'M ASSEMBLY MEMBER AREAS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR RIGHT ON A
HAVE TO SAY THAT I REALLY I
THINK THIS IS BEEN SUCH AN
IMPORTANT JOINT. COMMITTEE TO
TACKLE SUCH AN IMPORTANT ISSUE.
UP AS WAS MENTIONED.
BY SENATOR MITCHELL WE'VE HEARD
FROM TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY ONE EXPERTS AND WE'VE
LEARNED SO MUCH I THINK ONE OF
THE.
ONE OF THE KEY THINGS LIKE MY
TAKE AWAY IS THE NEED FOR THE
CHANGE IN CULTURE. I THINK THAT
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND I
THINK THAT I ONE. DAY I WANTED
TO COMMENT ALSO THAT. WE FOUNDED
THAT'S OR LEAST I FOUND THAT
THERE IS SUCH A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN MANAGING AN OFFICE OR
MANAGING AN INSTITUTION. AND
SHOWING LEADERSHIP IN AN OFFICE
OR IN AN INSTITUTION. I THINK
THE THE THE EMPHASIS HAS TO BE
IN LEADERSHIP AND SETTING THE
TONE WHETHER IT'S IN IN THIS
INSTITUTION OR IN OUR RESPECTIVE
OFFICES. AND FROM THAT WE
LEARNED SO MUCH BECAUSE IT SETS
THE TONE FOR THE REST OF THE
STAFF.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR MORLOCK THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AS SENATOR
MITCHELL ANSWERED MY QUESTION.
BUT MAYBE I COULD.
ASK A LITTLE MORE.
.
WE HAVE SELECTED A VENDOR YES
AND DO WE HAVE A TIME LINE
SPECIFIC.
LET ME GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT
BECAUSE I I DON'T KNOW THAT WAS
A PART OF THE INITIAL SCOPE OF
WORK.
I'M ASSUMING IN SOME OF THE
CONTRACT NEGOTIATIONS THAT MAY
HAVE BEEN A PART OF IT WE'VE NOT
BEEN DIRECTLY INVOLVED IN THAT.
RULES PASS.
BUT I AM NOW INSERTING MYSELF
UP TO CLEAN GIVEN THE DELAY AND
THE IMPACT IT'S HAVING ON THE
WORK OF THIS COMMITTEE. AND SO
I'LL GET BACK TO YOU.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT WITH REGARD
TO TIMELINE. AS MYSTERY OF SAID
YOU KNOW I I THINK WE ALL HAVE
HEARD IN AGREE THAT CULTURE AND
CULTURE SHIFT IS AN INTEGRAL
PART OF THIS AND THE WHOLE POINT
OF A CLIMATE SERBIA'S IT'S A
SNAPSHOT IN TIME. REALLY OF
CULTURE ON WHILE WE DO HAVE.
A MET METHODS AND MECHANISMS BY
WHICH PEOPLE CAN REPORT COMPLAIN
EXPRESSED CONCERN BUT THE
CLIMATE SURVEY REALLY IS A
SNAPSHOT OF WHAT ARE WHAT WHAT
WHAT CURRENTLY IS.
AND SO.
YOU'VE HEARD ME SAY IN THE PAST
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT NOT TO
RUSH PROPHECIES BUT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY ARE THOROUGH.
THAT ASIDE I'LL I WILL BE ASKING
THE QUESTIONS ABOUT TIMING OF
THE VENDOR IN TERMS OF WHAT WE
EXPECT AND AND WANT TO ECHO ON
OUR CHAIR WOMAN'S. POINT ABOUT
REALLY STRONGLY ENCOURAGING
EVERY EMPLOYEE TO TAKE THE TIME
TO PARTICIPATE IN A CLIMATE
SURVEY ON BECAUSE THAT IS OUR
WAY OF GETTING THE SENSE OF
WHAT.
YOUR EXPERIENCE IS CURRENTLY
ASSA EMPLOYEE IN THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LEGISLATURE.
I'LL GET BACK TO YOU ONCE I HAVE
A SENSE OF THE TIMING WILL LET
YOU KNOW.
YOU'RE HAVING FUN DOING
INDEPENDENT RESEARCH YES LOOKING
AT THE RESULTS OF ANOTHER SURVEY
YES AND.
I DON'T NO FOOD THE CONTRACTOR
WAS OUR THE FIRM BUT.
THE RESULTS FOR A LYNCHING SO
YOU CAN'T FIND TO SEE HOW IT
LINES UP WITH.
HOUSE CONDUCTED HERE AND THE
RESULTS OF WHAT THE A SURVEY OF
OF INDUSTRY WIDE PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL SIN AND IF IN MY CASE
FOR ACCOUNTANTS GOT IT
ACCOUNTING FIRMS WHICH I CAN
RELATE TO YES JUST WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF.
MEN AND WOMEN HAVE FELT THAT
THERE WAS EVEN. A PROBLEM. AND
IF SO JUST SERVICE IF I WAS.
KIND OF LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
RESULTS TO SEE HOW IT COMPARES
WITH BUT JUST THE INDEPENDENT I
HOPE YOU'LL SHARE THOSE FINDINGS
WITH US AND IT WILL BE IMPORTANT
TO KIND AYE. TO TO MEASURE
OURSELVES.
AGAINST
OTHER INDUSTRIES I THINK WE DO
THAT AROUND SALARY SURVEYS AND
OTHERS AND IT'S IMPORTANT WE WE
WE KNOW WHAT THE EXPERIENCE IS
LIKE CRITICALLY AS AS WE WORK
EVERYDAY TO ATTRACT TOP TALENT
TO WORK IN THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE. WE NEED TO KNOW
WHAT WITH THE UNIVERSE HEELS IN
TERMS OF THE SAME KIND OF
ISSUES.
I HOPE YOU'LL SHARE THAT WITH
THAT PHRASE YOU KNOW SOONER BUT
I KNOW THAT NOW THAT YOU'RE ON
TOP OF IT. IT SHOULDN'T TAKE TOO
LONG ALRIGHT SENATOR MY
COLLEAGUE HAS FAITH IN ME SO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I FRIEDMAN AND
I WILL DO WHAT WE CANNOT BEHALF
OF THE COMMITTEE TO. THINK WHERE
THAT PROCESS IS AND KEEP YOU
ALL.
TOOBIN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
SO WITHOUT WILL BRING OUR PANEL
UP.
KATHY RUFINO FROM TRAIN ME
TODAY AND PATTY PEREZ FROM M.
TRAIN.
AND I WILL ALLOW EACH OF YOU TO
INTRODUCE YOURSELVES AS YOU SEE
FIT.
AND THEN TO GO INTO THEIR
PRESENTATIONS.
HAD ALL ASK THE COMMITTEE TO
HOLD ANY QUESTIONS UNTIL WE'VE
HEARD BOTH PRESENTATIONS.
AND AS YOU'RE TAKING YOUR SEATS
LIKE THIS ONE APOLOGIZE.
THAT THE WE HAVE SIMULTANEOUS
COMMITTEES HAPPENING CENTER LATE
ENOUGH WILL HAVE TO RUN TO HELP
COMMITTEE TO ADD ON BOATS.
BUT WILL BE BACK BUT SO PLEASE
FORGIVE US.
IT'S WELCOME.
THE FIRST.
OKAY.
MY NAME IS KATHERINE FINO I AM
A HUMAN RESOURCES PROFESSIONAL
WITHOUT TWENTY YEARS IN HR.
ALAS SINCE TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
AS A CONSULTANT.
A FUTURE.
HOW'S THAT BETTER. OKAY.
.
SO CHAIR WOMAN FRIEDMAN
CHARWOMAN MITCHELL. AND THE
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M CUT THEIR FEE NO
MUCH TRAINER AND CONSULTANT FOUR
EIGHT FOR TRAINING TODAY. I
APPEARED BEFORE YOU TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE SOCIETY OF HUMAN
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT SHARM.
THE WORLD'S LARGEST HR
PROFESSIONAL SOCIETY
REPRESENTING TWO HUNDRED NINETY
THOUSAND MEMBERS INCLUDING
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA.
SURE MEMBERS IN TURN INFLUENCED
THE LIVES OF OVER ONE HUNDRED
MILLION INDIVIDUALS WORK IN THE
WORK FORCE. WHICH IS ABOUT ONE
IN THREE AMERICANS.
SO LET ME GIVE A LITTLE
BACKGROUND ON US TRAIN YOU DAY
HAS BEEN PASSIONATE ABOUT
WORKING IN THE HR FIELD FOR
DECADES AND HAS TRANSLATED THAT
KNOWLEDGE INTO A SUCCESSFUL
BUSINESS THAT TRAINS INDIVIDUALS
AND ORGANIZATIONS OF ALL SIZES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
LAUNCHED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
THREE BEFORE THE REQUIREMENTS OF
AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY FIVE.
BECAME LAW WEEK TRAINING TODAY
WAS CREATED TO PROVIDE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PREVENTION TRAINING
TO PRIVATE EMPLOYERS.
TRAINING TODAY HAS TRAINED
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIA CITIZENS AND SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PREVENTION AND HAS
STRIVE TO CREATE. A RESPECTFUL
WORKPLACE THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN
ALONE WE TRAINED OVER FOUR
THOUSAND PEOPLE MADE UP OF
SEASONED H. R. PRACTITIONERS
TRAIN ME TODAY IS DEDICATED TO
HELPING EMPLOYEES EMPLOYERS ARE.
CREATE RESPECTFUL WORKPLACES SO
ALL STAKEHOLDERS NGUYEN.
SO AS YOU HEARD THE SHERMANS
USHER IN CEO PRESIDENT.
JOHNNY C. TAYLOR JUNIOR SAY IN
JANUARY WHEN HE SPOKE BEFORE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
CULTURE TRUMP'S POLICY.
AND WORKPLACES MUST CREATE A
WHOLE LISTA CULTURE OF ON ON
HARASSMENT THAT STARTS AT THE
TOP.
MISTER TAYLOR. IS ALSO SAID THAT
COMPANIES CAN'T TO SOLELY RELY
ON COMPLIANCE.
WHETHER THAT BE RULES EDUCATION
AND TRAINING.
HOWEVER HE MADE CLEAR THAT THE
RULES EDUCATION AND TRAINING ARE
NECESSARY IF WE WANT TO MOVE
FORWARD AND ELIMINATE
HARASSMENT.
IN ORDER FOR AN ORGANIZATION TO
FULLY SUCCEED AT ELIMINATING
HARASSMENT IN THE WORKPLACE IT
MUST FOCUS ON BOTH ESTABLISHING
AN APPROPRIATE CULTURE IN
IMPLEMENTING AN APPROPRIATE
TRAINING PROGRAM.
TOO OFTEN ORGANIZATIONS FOCUS
TOO MUCH ON THE TRAINING AND NOT
ENOUGH ON THE CULTURE OR VICE
VERSA.
OBVIOUSLY SEXUAL HARASSMENT IS A
MAJOR ISSUE IN OUR COUNTRY RIGHT
NOW.
I WOULDN'T BE HERE SPEAKING TO
YOU IF THAT WAS NOT THE CASE FOR
THE MEDIA OF OF SORRY FROM THE
MEDIA TO GOVERNMENT. THE SYSTEM
HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED AS BROKEN.
THE US EQUAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY COMMISSION AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING HAVE EACH
RECOGNIZE THE SEXUAL HARASSMENT
IS A SYSTEMIC PROBLEM.
SURE BELIEVES THE ONE MAJOR STEP
IN FIXING THE BROKEN SYSTEM.
THAT THE LET THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATORS FACING IS TO
IMPLEMENT SUCCESSFUL SO SIR
SEXUAL HARASSMENT TRAINING
PROGRAM.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT TRAINER SUCH
AS TRAIN ME TODAY HAVE BEEN
CONDUCTING WORKPLACE TRAINING
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY.
OVER TIME WE HAVE SEEN AWARENESS
OF THE EMPLOYEE AND SUPERVISOR
LEVEL GROW. BUT LESS SO AT THE
SENIOR MANAGEMENT LEVEL.
WITH THE PASSAGE OF AB EIGHTEEN
TWENTY FIVE IN TWO THOUSAND SIX
SENIOR MANAGERS. HAVE BEEN
REQUIRED TO TAKE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT TRAINING EVERY TWO
YEARS.
SINCE THE LAW'S ENACTMENT ARE
PRACTICES SEEN A SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENT IN SENIOR MANAGEMENT
AWARENESS OF THEIR OBLIGATIONS.
IF ANY TRAINING IS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL SENIOR MANAGEMENT
AWARENESS OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT TRAINING IS
NECESSARY.
THE FOLLOWING ARE AYS IN WHICH
AN ORGANIZATION CAN CREATE AN
IMPLEMENT THE SUCCESSFUL.
TRAINING PROGRAM.
SO WE NEED MANAGEMENT BY END AT
THIS TIME IN OUR STATE'S HISTORY
MORE THAN ANY TIME BEFORE WE ARE
FINDING THAT SENIOR MANAGERS ARE
TAKING A MORE ACTIVE ROLE IN THE
TRAINING AND TAKING A PROACTIVE
ROLE IN SUPPORTING. A RESPECTFUL
WORKPLACE.
WHEN LEADERSHIP TAKES ON THE
ROLE OF MODELING OR CIRCLE A
RESPECTFUL WORKPLACE THE REST OF
THE WORKPLACE WILL FOLLOW.
AS OUR ELECTED STATE LEGISLATORS
WE LOOK TO YOU FOR OUR
LEADERSHIP.
NOT ONLY HERE IN THE CAPITAL BUT
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE.
ATTENDING AND PARTICIPATING IN
SEXUAL HARASSMENT TRAINING IS
ELECTED OFFICIALS WILL SEND A
STRONG MESSAGE.
BUT THE LEGISLATOR TAKES THIS
ISSUE SERIOUSLY.
SO TOO WILL ENSURING THAT SENIOR
LEVEL EMPLOYEES FULLY
PARTICIPATE IN TRAINING WHEN
SENIOR STAFF EVADE TRAINING ON
HARASSMENT DO TO WORKLOAD
SCHEDULING CONFLICTS OR OTHER
STATED REASONS. EMPLOYEES NOT
ONLY DISMISS THE TRAINING AS
WELL BUT THEY MAY NOT TAKE ANY
TRAINING. BURKE HARASSING
CONDUCT IN THE WORKPLACE
SERIOUSLY EITHER.
IN ORDER FOR TRAINING TO BE
EFFECTIVE IT MUST BE ENDORSED BY
THE LEADERS.
WE'VE ALSO SEEN THAT LIVE
TRAINEES HAS HAS EXCEEDED ONLINE
TRAINING INEFFECTIVENESS
OVERALL.
I BELIEVE THIS IS DUE TO THE
INTERACTION OF THE LIVE CLASS
AND THE ABILITY OF PARTICIPANTS
TO ASK QUESTIONS RECEIVE ANSWERS
ENGAGE IN DISCUSSION IN REAL
TIME.
SOME COMPANIES HAVE SUCCESS HAVE
SEEN SUCCESS A BLENDED APPROACH
AND THAT INCLUDES SOME LIFE
TRAINING AND SOME ONLINE
TRAINING.
THE ONLINE TRAINING CAN BE USED
A SUNDAY UNIFORM MESSAGE ACROSS
THE ENTIRE ORGANIZATION AND
REACH SOME EMPLOYEES THAT DO TO
UNIQUE SCHEDULES WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO TAKE THE LIVE TRAINING.
DURING NORMAL BUSINESS HOURS.
THE LIVE TRAINING COMPONENT CAN
THEN BE USED TO BUILD OFF THE
FOUNDATION STEP BY THE ONLINE
TRAINING. WITHOUT THE SPECIAL
NEEDS OF A LARGER REMOTE
WORKFORCE THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD
STRONGLY CONSIDER CONDUCTING
LIVE TRAINING TO ALLOW FOR MORE
ROBUST INTERACTION BETWEEN
TRAINER IN PARTICIPANTS.
WE ALSO WANT ADDRESS BYSTANDER
TRAINING IT'S NO SURPRISE THAT
EMPLOYEES FREQUENTLY BECOME
AWARE OF HARASSMENT ISSUES LONG
BEFORE MANAGEMENT.
YET THEY OFTEN FAIL TO REPORT.
THE MOST COMMON REASONS FOR THIS
OUR RELUCTANCE TO BECOME
INVOLVED LEST THEY BECOME THE
TARGET.
ASSUMPTIONS OF SOMEONE ELSE WILL
REPORT IT.
UNAWARE OF REPORTING PROCESS.
AND THE MERE THEIR PEERS SO OF
THEIR PEERS STAY SILENT SO WILL
THEY.
EMPLOYEES NEED TO BE TRAINED ON
THEIR ROLES AS BYSTANDERS IN THE
AVENUES THAT THEY HAVE AVAILABLE
TO THEM FOR REPORTING ANY
WORKPLACE HARASSMENT.
TRAINING PROGRAMS NEED TO
ADDRESS THE EMPLOYEES
RESPONSIBILITIES IN HELPING TO
FOSTER HARASSMENT FREE WORKPLACE
HOW EMPLOYEES FILE REPORT AND
THE INSURANCE OF NO RETALIATION.
BYSTANDER TRAINING CAN EASILY BE
INCORPORATED INTO THE HARASSMENT
PREVENTION TRAINING WHICH
ELIMINATES THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL TRAINING COURSES.
SO WE ALSO HAVE THE ISSUE OF
IMPLICIT BIAS.
AND I RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE
UNCONSCIOUS IMPLICIT BIASES THAT
EVERYONE BRINGS INTO THE
WORKPLACE AND THAT TRAINING IN
THIS AREA IS NECESSARY. FOR
CREATING A POSITIVE ENVIRONMENT.
MUCH OF THE TRAINING WE HAVE
SEEN IN THE PAST HAS FOCUSED ON
DEFINING WHAT IMPLICIT BIAS IS
AND TELLING PEOPLE THAT THEY
NEED TO BE AWARE OF THEIR
BEHAVIOR. AND THAT IT MAY BE A
PRO BEEN APPROPRIATE.
HOWEVER EFFECTIVE TRAINING NEEDS
TO BE MORE THAN JUST SIMPLE
AWARENESS.
IT MUST INCORPORATE METHODS FOR
IDENTIFYING WHAT IMPLICIT BIAS
LOOKS LIKE IN ACTION.
AND THE OPPORTUNITIES TO PUT
INTO PRACTICE A DIFFERENT
APPROACH THAT HELPS EMPLOYEES TO
CHANGE.
TRAINING PARTNERED WITH AN
ENVIRONMENT THE VALUES EACH
PERSON EQUALLY AND THE
LEADERSHIP THAT FOSTERS A
RESPECTFUL WORKPLACE ON ALL
LEVELS WILL PRODUCE SIGNIFICANT
AND SUSTAINABLE CHANGE.
SO I CAUTION YOU.
AGAINST USING COST AS A
DETERMINING FACTOR WHEN YOU'RE
CHOOSING A TRAINING PROP FORM.
EFFECTIVE TRAINING SHOULD
INVOLVE ALL HAVE HOLES OF
PERSONNEL INCLUDING INTERNS PAID
STAFF AND ELECTED OFFICIALS.
TRAINING FOR MANAGERS AND
EXECUTIVES HOWEVER SHOULD BE
SEPARATE SHOULD BE SEPARATE FROM
THE TRAINING FOR THE REST OF THE
EMPLOYEES.
AS MUCH AS YOU MAY WANT TO
CREATE A UNIFORM PROGRAM.
MANAGERS HAVE SPECIAL
RESPONSIBILITIES AND NEED TO BE
EDUCATED ON THESE
RESPONSIBILITIES IN ADDITION TO
INFORMATION PROVIDED TO ALL
EMPLOYEES.
SO HOW DO WE OVERCOME TRAINING
OBSTACLES WILL. AT IT ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT MANY ORGANIZATIONS
RUN INTO WITH REGARD TO SEXUAL
HARASSMENT TRAINING IS BOREDOM.
REDUNDANCY.
OR A LACKLUSTER ATTITUDE FROM
THE EMPLOYEES.
AND WE'VE ALL EXPERIENCED.
ONE SOLUTION IS TO SPREAD
TRAINING OVER THREE OR MORE
SHORT WORKSHOPS THAT ARE HELD
ONCE PER QUARTER INSTEAD OF ONE
LONG DAY OF TRAINING.
SOME ORGANIZATIONS HAVE ENTICED
EMPLOYEES AND OFFERED BREAKFAST
OR LUNCH OR EVEN DRAWINGS FOR
GIFT CARDS.
AND AS I STATED EARLIER
EMPLOYEES WILL ASSUME THE
ATTITUDE OF THE LEADERS IN THE
ORGANIZATION IF THEY SEE THE
LEADERS OPENLY EMBRACING THE
TRAINING. THEY WILL FOLLOW.
SO TO CONCLUDE THERE IS NO DOUBT
THAT TRAINING IS AN INTEGRAL
PART OF ERADICATING HARASSMENT
IN THE WORKPLACE. AS PART OF
SHARON'S RECOGNITION OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF TRAINING WE HAVE
CREATED SEPARATE SAMPLE
PRESENTATIONS FOR EMPLOYEE AND
MANAGER TRAINING FOR OUR MEMBERS
TO USE. AND CUSTOMIZE TO MATCH
THEIR OWN POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES.
IN ADDITION WE HAVE COMPLETE WE
HAVE A COMPLETE LIST OF
WORKPLACE HARASSMENT TRAINING
RESOURCES FOR OUR MEMBERS TO
UTILIZE.
TRAINING ALONE HOWEVER IS NOT
ENOUGH.
LEADERS LEADERSHIP.
IS THE KEY WITHIN AN
ORGANIZATION WHETHER IT BE AN
INDIVIDUAL SENATOR. AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DOWN THROUGH THE CHIEFS
OF STAFF AT THE IN THE CAPITOL
OFFICES.
SENDING A CLEAR AND STRONG
STATEMENT THAT YOUR OFFICE WILL
NOT CONDONE OR TOLERATE ANY FORM
OF HARASSMENT OF ANY INDIVIDUAL
WORKING YOUR OFFICE OR COMING
INTO CONTACT. WITH YOUR OFFICE
IS SOMETHING YOU CAN DO OUTSIDE
OF FORMAL TRAINING PROGRAMS.
LEADERSHIP FROM THE TOP IS A
GOOD START IN ESTABLISHING A
CULTURE OF RESPECT AND
INCLUSION.
AND THE SOONER IT IS EMBRACE AND
PUT INTO PRACTICE THE BETTER FOR
ALL THOSE WHO WORK IN IRAQ WITH
YOUR OFFICE.
SO THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO APPEAR BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
INSURANCE COMMITTED TO WORK WITH
THE COMMITTEE AS IT ADDRESSES
THE IMPORTANT ISSUE AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR QUESTIONS.
THINKS I ACTUALLY HAVE A. POWER
POINT TO MATURE HOW WE GET
TURNED ON.
BEING HERE.
PARA A.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRWOMAN
AND THEN VICE CHAIRWOMAN AND
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ON SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PREVENTION AND
RESPONSE.
I AM HONORED TO BE OUT TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY. ON A TOPIC
THAT IS NEAR AND DEAR TO ME AND
ONE WHICH I DEDICATED MY ENTIRE
TWENTY FIVE PLUS YEAR CAREER. AS
AN EMPLOYMENT ATTORNEY IN HR
EXECUTIVE A BUSINESS OWNER ALLOW
FROM SHAREHOLDER. AN EXPERT
WITNESS AND PERHAPS THE GREATEST
INTEREST TO THIS COMMITTEE AS
THE PRINCIPAL AUTHOR OF
REGULATIONS CLARIFYING CIVIL
RIGHTS LAWS AN EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE
RELATIONS IN CALIFORNIA.
MY NAME IS PATTI PRESIDENT THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF WORKPLACE
STRATEGY FOR AND TRAIN. A
COMPANY THAT'S HEADQUARTERED
HERE IN SACRAMENTO WITH OFFICES
IN SAN FRANCISCO AND I'M FROM
SAN DIEGO SO I WAS VERY HAPPY TO
SEE THAT I HAVE SOME OF MY VERY
OWN HERE ON THIS COMMITTEE.
ALRIGHT MY PRESENTATION TODAY IS
GOING TO CONSIST OF FOUR PARTS.
WHAT'S REQUIRED.
WHAT HASN'T WORKED WHAT IS A
RESEARCH SHOW ON THAT?
WHAT'S CHANGED AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY WHAT DOES WORK AND
WHAT SHOULD WE BE DOING.
SO WE START WITH A REALLY BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF WHAT'S CURRENTLY
REQUIRED.
AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY FIVE AB
TWENTY FIFTY THREE AND S. B.
THREE NINETY SIX TOGETHER.
REQUIRE THAT EMPLOYERS WITH
FIFTY OR MORE EMPLOYEES PROVIDE
TWO HOURS OF TRAINING EVERY TWO
YEARS. TO ITS MANAGERS AND
SUPERVISORS.
THE TRAIN SHOULD COVER DETAILS
RELATED TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT
INCLUDING LEGAL DEFINITIONS
EXAMPLES. METHODS FOR LODGING
COMPLAINTS REMEDIES AVAILABLE TO
VICTIMS AND A COPY OF THE
COMPANY'S HARASSMENT PREVENTION
POLICY AMONG OTHER REQUIREMENTS.
AND TRAINING WAS ALSO COVER
ISSUES RELATED TO ABUSE OF
CONDUCT OR BULLYING.
IT AND ISSUES RELATED TO SEXUAL
ORIENTATION GENDER IDENTITY AND
GENDER EXPRESSION.
AND WELL VERSED ON THE
DEFINITIONS OF REQUIREMENTS FOR
IMPLEMENTATIONS OF THESE
TRAINING.
MANDATES SINCE AS I PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED IN MY ROLE AS A MEMBER
OF THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT HOUSING
COUNCIL. I WAS THE PRIMARY
AUTHOR OF IMPLEMENTING
REGULATIONS RELATED TO THESE
REQUIREMENTS. AND I ALSO HELPED
DRAFT REGULATIONS RELATED TO
SEXUAL HARASSMENT GENDER
IDENTITY AND GENDER EXPRESSION.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS BUT IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME ALL MOVE ON TO HOW WE GOT
HERE AND HOW WE CAN MAKE THINGS
BETTER.
SO FIRST WHAT HASN'T WORKED.
MIMI NERD BY NATURE SO WHEN
ADDITION TO BEING.
AN EMPLOYMENT ATTORNEY I ALSO
HAVE BECOME VERY WELL VERSED IN
PSYCHOLOGY AND OTHER.
AREAS SOCIAL PSYCHOLOGY THAT
TALK ABOUT OTHER OF RESEARCH
THESE TOPICS.
AND SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT WE
KNOW.
HAVE GOTTEN US WHERE WE ARE
TODAY AND WHAT DOESN'T WORK IN
TERMS OF TRAINING INCLUDE.
NUMBER ONE A CHECK THE BOX
MENTALITY.
SO TRAINING HAS BEEN INEFFECTIVE
BECAUSE IT HAS FOR THE MOST
PART.
FOCUS SOLELY ON ISSUES RELATED
TO LEGAL COMPLIANCE.
THIS CONCLUSION WAS EXPRESSED
POWERFULLY IN A TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN REPORT ISSUED BY THE
EEOC SELECT TASK FORCE ON
HARASSMENT PREVENTION.
WHEN THE MESSAGE GIVEN TO
EMPLOYEES IS THAT WERE ONLY
INTERESTED IN COMPLYING WITH THE
MINIMUM LEGAL STANDARDS BUT
NOTHING ELSE.
THE DATA SHOWS THAT THE TRAINING
WILL NOT ONLY BE INEFFECTIVE BUT
WILL ACTUALLY HAVE A BACKLASH
EFFECT.
ANOTHER ROOT CAUSE IS STANDALONE
TRAINING.
HARASSMENT PREVENTION TRAINING
DOES NOT ACHIEVE THE DESIRED
EFFECT IF IT DOESN'T INCLUDE THE
INCLUSION OF NECESSARY TOPICS
SUCH AS IMPLICIT BIAS. DIVERSITY
IN EQUITY.
ABILITY AND RESPECT.
BYSTANDER TRAINING COMMUNICATION
TRAINING AND CONFLICT RESOLUTION
TRAINING.
SINCE THESE TOPICS CAN'T BE
COVERED IN THE REQUIRED TWO
HOURS THREE USUALLY IGNORED.
THAT ALL EMPLOYEES AND MANAGERS
LEARN. IS THE LEGAL LANGUAGE OF
UNLAWFUL HARASSMENT.
UNREALISTIC EXAMPLES. WE HEAR
OVER AND OVER FROM EMPLOYEES AND
MANAGERS ALIKE THAT WORKPLACE
SCENARIOS WHETHER LIVOR ONLINE.
INCLUDE UNREALISTIC EXAGGERATED
AND OBVIOUS EXAMPLES OF
WORKPLACE MISCONDUCT.
WORDS I'VE HEARD TO DESCRIBE
THIS TYPE OF TRAINING WILL RANGE
FROM BORING.
CHEESY.
AND THEY ALL POINT TO A FEELER
NOT ONLY TO PAY ATTENTION BUT
CERTAINLY THERE'S NO LEARNING
BEING INVOLVED WINDOWS OF THE
TYPES OF SCENARIOS THAT ARE
BEING USED.
ANOTHER IS NOT BEING FOCUSED ON
TRUE UNDERSTANDING. AND BEHAVIOR
CHANGE
THE RESEARCH SHOWS IS THAT
HARASSMENT THAT PUTS THE BLAME
ON ONE SIDE AND FAILS TO PROMOTE
UNDERSTANDING EMPATHY AND
CLARITY. HAS ZERO EFFECT ON
BEHAVIOR.
ANOTHER ISSUE IS THE LACK OF
AUTHENTICITY.
THE PEOPLE WHO AREN SUCCEED AND
TRADING IS BECAUSE THEY ALREADY
BELIEVE IF THEY WORK FOR AN
ORGANIZATION THAT VALUES AT SIX
RESPECT AND INCLUSION.
WITHOUT THAT FOUNDATION THE
TRAINING IS VIEWED AS
INAUTHENTIC AND IS THEREFORE
INEFFECTIVE.
AND ANOTHER ISSUE IS THAT WHERE
THE VIEW IS THAT REPORTING IS
FUTILE.
ASK YOURSELF DO YOU HAVE A
POSITIVE CYCLE OF REPORTING
INVESTIGATING AND RESOLVING.
IF NOT THEN EMPLOYEES ARE GONNA
BELIEVE IT THEIR COMPLAINTS WILL
BE TAKEN SERIOUSLY AND TRAINING
IN THIS ENVIRONMENT DOES NOTHING
TO MOVE THE NEEDLE.
WHAT'S CHANGED WHY ARE WE HERE
TODAY.
SO NOT EVERYTHING THAT IS FACE
CAN BE CHANGED BUT NOTHING CAN
BE CHANGED UNTIL IT IS FACED.
AND ALTHOUGH THERE ARE CERTAINLY
A NUMBER OF LEGAL SOCIOLOGICAL
HISTORICAL. AND OTHER ROOT
CAUSES.
THAT EXPLAINED THIS VERY COMPLEX
ISSUE. WE NEED TO FACE THE
REALITY THAT TODAY.
WE ARE AT A VERY IMPORTANT
MOMENT IN TIME.
SO AS I MENTIONED AT THE OUTSET
ONE OF THE MANY HATS I'VE WORN
DURING MY PROFESSIONAL CAREER IS
THAT OF WORKPLACE PROBLEM
SOLVER.
I CONDUCTED IN EXCESS OF TWELVE
HUNDRED WORKPLACE INVESTIGATIONS
DURING MY CAREER.
I HAVE A LOT OF STORIES.
MY INVESTIGATIONS COVER EVERY
TYPE OF SEXUAL HARASSER EVERY
TYPE OF ALLEGATION AND MOST OF
THEM CONCERN SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
AND WHILE I'VE HAD EVERY VERSION
OF ALLEGATION YOU CAN IMAGINE.
INVOLVING DIFFERENT GENDERS
INVOLVING SAME GENDER ETCETERA.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
HARASSMENT CLAIMS STILL HAVE TWO
CHARACTERISTICS IN COMMON.
THE PERSON COMPLAINING IS A
WOMAN.
AND THE PERSON THEY'RE
COMPLAINING ABOUT IS A MAN IN A
GREATER POSITION OF POWER.
SO WITH THAT AS A BACK TO BACK
DROP HERE'S SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT I'VE SEEN OVER AND OVER
AGAIN IN THE WORKPLACE THAT I
THINK EXPLAIN HOW WE GET TO THIS
ME TO IN TIMES OF MOMENT THAT WE
FIND OURSELVES AND.
WHEN I TALKED ABOUT ALREADY AND
THAT IS COMPLIANCE BLINDERS OR A
CULTURE OF COMPLIANCE.
BORROWING FROM ONE OF MY
FAVORITE COMEDIAN SETH MEYERS I
WOULD SAY THAT.
I LOVE WORKING FOR A CULTURE OF
OUR COMPANIES THAT VALUES
COMPLIANCE WITH SAID BY NO
EMPLOYEE EVER.
SO THROUGH OUR EMPHASIS IN
PROVIDING HARASSMENT FREE
WORKPLACE WE'VE MISSED THE MARK
AND FAILED TO FOCUS ON WHAT
REALLY MATTERS WHICH IS
PROVIDING A HEALTHY WORKPLACE
CULTURE.
ONE THING I FAILED TO MENTION IN
MY INTRODUCTION OF THAT I'M A
NATIVE OF EL SALVADOR. AND SO AS
A RESULT DE CHOSE WHICH OR
SAYINGS IN SPANISH ARE A BIG
PART OF MY CULTURE AND SO I COME
UP WITH A LOT OF SORT OF PITHY
SAYINGS. AND ONE OF THE ONE THAT
I COME UP FOR THIS CULTURE OF
COMPLIANCE IS. IN PROMISING A
HARASSMENT FREE WORKPLACE.
IN MANY WAYS IS SIMILAR TO A
RESTAURANT SAYING WE PROMISE NOT
TO GIVE YOU FOOD POISONING.
SO WE'LL DO THE MINIMUM. BUT
THAT'S ALL WE'RE GONNA DO. NOT
EXACTLY THE TYPE OF COMPANY THAT
YOU WANT TO WORK FOR ENTITY ONE
OR FOURTH.
ANOTHER AND. ROUTE ISSUE IS NO
EARLY INTERVENTION.
BECAUSE TRAINING AND MANY
CORPORATE PRACTICES FOCUSED ON
THE PREVENTION AND RESOLUTION OF
UNLAWFUL. CONDUCT.
WE'VE DEVELOPED AN OVERALL
CULTURE THAT IGNORES PROBLEMS AT
AN EARLY STAGE WHEN PROBLEMS ARE
STILL FIXABLE.
IN THE REGULATIONS THAT WE
DRAFTED FOR THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING COUNCIL SOMETHING I
INSISTED ON WAS REALLY ROOTED IN
LOOKING AT THE LEGISLATIVE
HISTORY IN LEGISLATIVE LANGUAGE.
OF AN EMPLOYER'S OBLIGATION TO
TAKE REASONABLE STEPS TO PREVENT
INCORRECT HARASSMENT.
WHAT I INSIST ON WAS LANGUAGE
THAT TRACKED DOT STATUTORY ON
HISTORY?
AND SAID THAT EMPLOYERS OUR
OBLIGATED TO TAKE STEPS TO TAKE
ACTION AND TO CORRECT
MISCONDUCT.
NOT UNLAWFUL CONDUCT
IF YOU WAIT UNTIL IT'S UNLAWFUL
WE'VE WAITED TOO LONG AND IT'S
TOO LATE.
AND IN ADDITION TO THAT BEING
THE LAW IT'S GOOD BUSINESS.
A CULTURE OF COMPLICITY.
TRAINING A CORPORATE CULTURE
THAT TOLERATES BAD BEHAVIOR
SIMPLY DOESN'T WORK.
AN IMBALANCE IN POWER AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER.
IS A HALLMARK OF MOORE'S MOST
HARASSMENT CLAIMS AND WE'VE SEEN
THIS OVER AND OVER AGAIN DURING
THE ME TO MOVEMENT.
THE FACT THAT THERE IS AN
IMBALANCE IN POWER IS THE ROOT
CAUSE OF MANY OF THE WOMEN WHO
HAVE COME FORWARD.
THIS IS SEEN IN ISSUES RELATED
TO PAY INEQUITY.
AS WELL AS A SMALL NUMBER OF
WOMEN IN KEY LEADERSHIP
POSITIONS.
SO COMBINING AN IMBALANCE OF
POWER WITH THE CULTURE OF
COMPLICITY. MEANS THAT TARGETS
OF BAD BEHAVIOR ARE DOUBLE
VICTIMIZED FIRST BY THE
PERPETRATOR. AND THEN BY AN
ORGANIZATION THAT TURNS THE
OTHER WAY AND FAILED TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES EARLY.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE WHEN THE
PERPETRATOR IS SEEN AS A HIGH
VALUE EMPLOYEE WHO SIMPLY CANNOT
BE LOST.
THEN ANOTHER ISSUE IS A FAILURE
TO REPORT.
SO STUDIES INDICATE THAT
ANYWHERE BETWEEN TWENTY FIVE AND
SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT OF WOMEN
WHO WERE SURVEYED SAY THAT
THEY'VE BEEN EXPOSED TO SOME
TYPE OF SEXUALLY HARASSING
BEHAVIOR.
WHY THE DISPARITY IT DEPENDS ON
HOW THE QUESTION OF IS ASKED IF
THE QUESTION IS SIMPLY HAVE YOU
BEEN SEXUALLY HARASSED? THEN WE
TEND TO SEE NUMBERS IN THE LOWER
RANGE.
IF ON THE OTHER HAND THE
QUESTION IS VERY SPECIFIC HAVE
YOU BEEN EXPOSED TO THIS TYPE OF
BEHAVIOR.
THEN THE NUMBER SHOOT UP.
THE LESSON IS CLEAR THAT IT IS
SOMETHING THAT UNFORTUNATELY
DOES STILL HAPPEN IN THE
WORKPLACE VERY OFTEN.
NOW GIVEN A NUMBER OF INTERNAL
REPORTS AND LAWSUITS.
THIS MEANS THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF INSTANCES OF
INAPPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR ARE NEVER
REPORTED.
EVEN ASSUMING THAT A FAIR
PERCENTAGE OF THOSE EXAMPLES OF
BAD BEHAVIOR ARE RESOLVED IN
SOME WAY. IT STILL LEAVES A HIGH
NUMBER OF CONCERNS UNADDRESSED
AND INCREASES THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT THAT BEHAVIOR WILL
ESCALATE.
ESPECIALLY IN A CULTURE OF
COMPLICITY WORD THE MESSAGE SENT
IS NOT ONLY TO ACCEPT YOUR
BEHAVIOR WE ENCOURAGE IT.
THE OTHER REASONS FOR FAILING TO
REPORT INCLUDE FEAR RETALIATION.
A FEELING OF OF FUTILITY. OF
FEAR OF BEING LABELLED AS A
TROUBLEMAKER.
OR FRANKLY JUST NOT KNOWING HOW
TO DO IT.
THERE'S A CORPORATE DISCONNECT
AS WELL THAT I THINK IS
IMPORTANT TO TALK ABOUT.
WE HAD AND TRAIN RECENTLY
PERFORMED A SURVEY WE'RE IN THE
PROCESS OF WRITING A WHITE PAPER
ABOUT IT. AND ONE OF THE THE
REALLY STARK FINDINGS FOR ME WAS
ONE OF THE PRELIMINARY QUESTIONS
THAT WE ASK GENERAL COUNSEL AT
CORPORATIONS WAS HOW. OFTEN DO
YOU THINK SEXUAL HARASSMENT
OCCURS IN YOUR PARTICULAR
WORKPLACE.
AND OVER FIFTY PERCENT OF OUR
RESPONDENTS SAYS IT NEVER
HAPPENS OR IT RARELY HAPPENS.
IT SOUNDS GOOD.
UNTIL YOU GET TO ABOUT TEN
QUESTIONS AFTER THAT.
AND THE QUESTION WAS.
ON A SCALE OF VERY COMFORTABLE
TO NOT COMFORTABLE AT ALL.
WHERE WOULD YOU RATE THE COMFORT
LEVEL THAT YOUR EMPLOYEES HAVE
REPORTING? BAD BEHAVIOR IN THE
WORKPLACE.
THIRTY THREE PERCENT SAID THAT
THEIR EMPLOYEES WERE VERY
COMFORTABLE ARE COMFORTABLE.
THAT'S A DISCONNECT.
YOU ALL KNOW THAT HARASSMENT IS
OCCURRING BECAUSE NO ONE'S
TELLING YOU ABOUT IT AND THE
QUESTION IS WHY AREN'T THEY
TELLING YOU ABOUT IT.
THESE STATISTICS SUPPLY.
A PRIVATE PUBLIC FOR PROFIT NOT
FOR PROFIT. UNIONIZED AND NON
UNIONIZED PLACES ALIKE WORK
PLACES LIKE.
SO.
WHERE DO WE GO FROM HERE WHAT
DOES WORK WHAT DOES EXPERIENCE
SHOW US?
NOW THAT WE KNOW THE CURRENT
STATE OF AFFAIRS LET'S TURN OUR
ATTENTION TO WHY WE'RE HERE TO
FIND SOLUTIONS.
AND SOLUTIONS THAT WILL NOT ONLY
BE EFFECTIVE BUT SOLUTIONS THAT
ARE DOABLE.
SO HERE ARE SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT I HAVE.
THE FIRST IS OBVIOUSLY WE'VE
BEEN FOCUSING ON TODAY AND I
THINK WHAT THE COMMITTEE HAS
BEEN FOCUSING ON WRIT LARGE
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THIS
WORK.
AND THAT IS FOSTERING A POSITIVE
RESPECTFUL AND INCLUSIVE
WORKPLACE CULTURE.
WE HAVE BEEN TREATING THE
SYMPTOMS AND NOT THE DISEASE AND
THAT'S A REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT
PART OF THIS.
YOU NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHATEVER Q. WORK YOU IMPLEMENT
FOR ALL WE KNOW IS A DISEASE
WHICH IS SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
THAT IS ACTUALLY IN LINE WITH
OTHER PIECES OF THE PUZZLE.
SO FOR EXAMPLE DEAR POLICIES AND
PRACTICES FOCUS SOLELY ON LEGAL
ISSUES. I HAD THE HONOR OF
RECENTLY REVIEWING I AM AND HAVE
FRIENDS WITH KEVIN KISHI WAS A
DIRECTOR OF THE DFP AGE. AND HE
SENT TO ME WHAT THE UP PROPOSED
LANGUAGE IS FOR A MODEL POLICY.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I'M
DISCUSSING WITH HIM ESPECIALLY
IN LIGHT OF THE FACT THAT WE ARE
THE CUTTING EDGE STATE THAT
EVERYBODY LOOKS TO AS A AS AN
EXAMPLE. IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT ONLY PROMISING THAT
WILL DO SOMETHING OF BEHAVIOR
THAT IS ILLEGAL IS SOMEHOW
IDENTIFIED. TO REALLY BE CUTTING
EDGE AND TALK IN OUR POLICIES
ABOUT HOW WE'RE GOING TO GO
BEYOND THAT WHAT EMPLOYEES READ
WHEN THEY READ A POLICY THAT
SAYS. WE DON'T TOLERATE
HARASSMENT THAT IS BASED ON A
PROTECTED CATEGORY IS BECAUSE OF
ITS NOT BASED ON A PROTECTED
CATEGORY. BUT IT'S FOR A GAME
AND WE REALLY NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WHATEVER WE DO IN TERMS OF
POLICIES AND PRACTICES. FALLS IN
LINE WITH SOME OF THE BIG
PICTURE IS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
EMBRACING A CULTURE OF TRUTH
TELLING THIS TO ME IS A VERY
VERY KEY.
IN A WORKPLACE THAT IT EMBRACES
THE IDEA OF BEING HEALTHY
RESPECTFUL INCLUSIVE AND
PRODUCTIVE. REPORTS OF POSSIBLE
MISCONDUCT SHOULD BE WELCOMED
AND SHOULD BE SEEN AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO IMPROVE THE
WORKPLACE.
FAILURE TO WELCOME COMPLAINTS
AND FAILURE TO ADDRESS THESE
CONCERNS DOES NOT MAKE THE
ISSUES GO AWAY IT SIMPLY ROBS US
OF THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
THEM AND TO FIX THEM.
AND ONE THING THAT IS
PARTICULARLY TRUE IN TRAINING IS
THAT THERE IS A FALLACY THAT
GOOD TRAINING SHOULD MEAN LESS
COMPLAINTS.
IT'S NOT ALWAYS TRUE SOMETIMES
GOOD TRAINING MEANS THAT PEOPLE
ARE COMFORTABLE ENOUGH TO COME
FORWARD AND ACTUALLY LODGE
CONCERNS AND ESPECIALLY IF
THEY'RE COMFORTABLE DOING SO. AT
THE EARLY STAGE FOR SOMETHING
CAN BE DONE.
ANOTHER ISSUE IS TEACHING A NEW
LANGUAGE AND PROVIDING TOOLS TO
COMMUNICATE PRECISELY AND
EFFECTIVELY.
NOT DEFENSIVELY AND IN A
CONFRONTATIONAL WAY.
WHEN WE ONLY TEACHER EMPLOYEES
AND MANAGERS LEGAL LANGUAGE IT'S
REASONABLE THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
THE TOOLS AND LANGUAGE NECESSARY
TO REPORT BEHAVIOR. AT THE POINT
WHERE IT CAN BE RESOLVED AS AN
EMPLOYEE RELATIONS ISSUE. RATHER
THAN IN THE PUBLIC RELATIONS
SPHERE OR AS A LEGAL ISSUE.
AND FINISHING IT OFF A COUPLE OF
OTHER RECOMMENDATIONS MICRO
LEARNING MANY LESSONS GUIDE
SUMMARIES SCRIPTS.
WE NEED TO SUPPLEMENT FORMAL
LEARNING SESSIONS WITH BURSTS OF
LEARNING TO REINFORCE WHAT IS
TAUGHT IN FORMAL TRAINING.
THE TRAINING NEEDS TO BE
PERSONALIZED ALLOWING FOR
QUESTIONS TO BE ASKED.
AND FOR PROVIDING ACCURATE
PRACTICAL AND REAL WORLD ANSWER
TO THOSE QUESTIONS.
WE NEED TO TAKE A PROGRAMMATIC
APPROACH SO FOR EMPLOYEES AND
MANAGERS. AND IN THE CONTEXT OF
THE LEGISLATURE THAT WOULD
INCLUDE LEGISLATORS CHIEFS OF
STAFF AND OTHER STAFFERS.
WE SHOULD BE TRADE AT THE VERY
LEAST SOME WHAT I CALL THE FIVE
ESSENTIALS HARASSMENT PREVENTION
IMPLICIT OR UNCONSCIOUS BIAS.
DIVERSITY INCLUSION BELONGING
CONFLICT RESOLUTION AND
COMMUNICATION SKILLS.
FREE CHARTER WOULD ADD ONE MORE
AND THIS WOULD BE IN THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
WITHIN THEIR PURVIEW AND THAT IS
TRAINING ON HOW TO RECEIVE
INVESTIGATE AND RESOLVE
COMPLAINTS.
THE SURVEY THAT ARE REFERENCED
EARLIER ACKNOWLEDGES THAT LESS
THAN FIFTY PERCENT OF
INVESTIGATORS.
AT LEAST ACCORDING TO THESE.
PEOPLE SURVEYED. ARE ACTUALLY
WELL TRAINED IN HOW TO
INVESTIGATE COMPLAINTS.
SO. THE BUDDHIST TEACHER SYLVIA
BORNSTEIN SAID WHEN WE SEE
CLEARLY WE BEHAVED IMPECCABLY.
THAT IN MY VIEW THE TASK AT
HAND.
IT'S TO CHANGE ISN'T TO CHANGE
BEHAVIOR BUT RATHER TO THINK
CLEARLY.
AND AS A BY PRODUCT.
BURNING BEHIND WILL BE HERE.
AND AS A BY PRODUCT OF THAT
UNDERSTANDING.
WE ACTUALLY WILL SEE BEHAVIOR
CHANGE.
SO THE FINAL THING THAT I
RECOMMEND.
IS THE COLLECTION AND USE OF
DATA.
I DEAL TRAINING WILL INCLUDE A
WAY TO TRACK ISSUES RELATED TO
WORKPLACE.
SUBJECT MATTERS THAT CAN BE
ANALYZED AND USED TO CREATE A
POSITIVE CYCLE OF REPORTING
INVESTIGATING AND RESOLVING
ISSUES EARLY.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR GIVING ME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE.
INFORMATION ON THIS TIMELY AND
IMPORTANT TOPIC.
THANK YOU THAT WAS ARE REALLY TO
TRAFFIC PRESENTATIONS I HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS THAT ARE MOVED TO
THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
.
AND I WROTE DOWN OUT OF SEVERAL
THINGS THAT YOU SAID A YOU KNOW
IT WAS VERY VERY HELPFUL AND
VERY MUCH IN LINE WITH WHAT
WE'VE BEEN HEARING FROM OTHERS
SPEAKERS ABOUT. OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF CULTURE CHANGE.
AND WORKING ON THOSE UNDERLYING
ISSUES THAT MAKE I'M. MAKE FOR
AN UNPLEASANT WORKPLACE ANNA AND
WORKPLACE IT'S NOT PROTECTIVE OF
EMPLOYEES OR THAT VALUES OF
EVERYBODY'S CONTRIBUTION SO
THANK YOU.
.
I'M WONDERING FIRST OF ALL ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT THAT JUROR
HAS TALKED ABOUT AND OTHERS IS
FINDING A WAY TO REINFORCE GOOD
BEHAVIOUR. BY HAVING WAY BY
MAKING IT CLEAR THAT WE ARE
LOOKING TO PROMOTE.
SUPERVISORS TO.
EMBODIED THE TYPE OF.
THE BEHAVIOR WE WANTED ALSO CAN
CREATE THE ATMOSPHERE THAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR IN THE VALUES THAT
WE WANT TO BRING TORN PLEASE SO.
DO YOU HAVE SUGGESTIONS ON HOW
YOU CAN FORMALIZE AND ENCOURAGE
THE PROMOTION OF MANAGERS AND
SUPERVISORS. THAT DO CREATE THE
TYPE OF WORKPLACE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SEE HOW DO YOU KIND OF
WRITE THAT INTO YOUR POLICIES
ARE MAKE THAT SOMETHING THAT'S
DONE.
YOU BOTH KNOW THAT YOU'RE GONNA
GET IT OUT OF THE TO GO KEEPING
IN MIND THAT WE TEND TO REWARD.
SORT OF TYPE A BEHAVIOR ARE YOU
KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO YOU
KNOW ARE KIND OF GOOD AT GETTING
LEGISLATION THROUGH WORK KNOW
ABOUT PARTICULAR ISSUES THAT
THAT BECOMES A THING HERE
SOMETIMES THAT SCENE IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT.
QUALITY TO HAVE AN END THAT'S
NOT UNLIKE OTHER INDUSTRIES
UNCERTAINLY AS A LAWYER I I SEE
THAT YOU KNOW PEOPLE WERE VERY
GOOD AT. A UNDERSTAND THE LAW.
AND AND LITIGATING CASES I'M
ALSO GET PROMOTED IN OTHER
ARENAS
PEOPLE WERE TECHNICALLY GOOD AT
THEIR JOBS GET PROMOTED WITHOUT
REALLY PAYING ATTENTION TO THIS.
PART OF THE SKILL SET SO TO
TOOL THAT I THINK ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT AND ARE UNDER
UTILIZED.
ONE IS A PERFORMANCE MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM AND THERE'S CERTAINLY A
LOT OF DEBATE WITHIN THE CHURCH
COMMUNITY WHETHER. THAT
CONTINUES TO BE AN ANNUAL REVIEW
WHETHER IT'S SOMETHING THAT
SHOULD BE DONE MORE OFTEN I FALL
ON THE SIDE OF IT SHOULD BE DONE
MORE OFTEN THAN THAT.
BUT IN WHATEVER MANNER THAT YOU
DO IT HAVING VERY MEASURABLE AND
SPECIFIC.
EXPECTATIONS BOTH OF BACKWARDS
LOOKING FORWARD LOOKING MEANING.
AT YOU KNOW AT THE OUTSET IS A
BASELINE YOU SAY HERE'S WHAT I
EXPECT FROM YOU OF COURSE I
EXPECT TO BE TECHNICALLY
PROFICIENT IN YOUR JOB. BUT IF
YOU ARE LOOKING TO BE IN A
MANAGEMENT POSITION AND ACTUALLY
OVERSEEING PEOPLE THAN THAT PART
OF IT IS ALSO GOING TO BE
IMPORTANT AND HERE'S WHAT WE
EXPECT.
AND THEN.
BACKWARD LOOKING IS ONCE YOU'VE
ESTABLISHED THAT EXPECTATION
MAKING SURE THAT THEY'RE MEETING
THAT. SO USING THE PERFORMANCE
EVALUATION.
OR PERFORMANCE MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM I THINK IS ONE REALLY
UNDER UTILIZED TOOL THE OTHER
UNDER UTILIZED TOOL WOULD BE
JUST THE JOB DESCRIPTION WHICH
GOES HAND IN HAND WITH THAT. AND
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE
EXPECTATIONS ARE MADE.
EXCEEDINGLY CLEAR TO THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE SEEKING THOSE POSITIONS.
AND FRANKLY THAT DAD THOSE
TOOLS ARE THEN USED TO EITHER.
.
AND.
ASSIST IN THE PROMOTION IN OTHER
WORDS YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE DOING A
GOOD JOB YOU GET REWARDED AS A
RESULT OF MEETING THOSE
EXPECTATIONS.
BUT.
IF IT'S REALLY GOING TO BE AN
IMPORTANT PART OF JOB JOB
DESCRIPTION AND PERFORMANCE
MANAGEMENT THEN YOU ALSO GET
DIDN'T FRANKLY IF YOU'RE NOT
DOING THAT.
AND THAT'S KIND OF THE IDEA OF
THE HIGH VALUE EMPLOYEE THAT I
TALKED ABOUT IS THAT TOO OFTEN
PEOPLE WILL OVERLOOK.
DEFICIENCIES WHEN IT COMES TO
PEOPLE MANAGEMENT IF YOUR
EXCELLENT TECHNICALLY AND THAT'S
GONNA CHANGE.
I'M WE HEARD ON OUR LAST.
.
A HEARING FROM OF SOMEBODY WHO
WORKS IN THE RESTORED OF JUSTICE
SERENA AND WHAT WAS INTERESTING
WAS THAT THEY WERE PRESENTING
THE RESORT OF JUSTICE TECHNIQUES
NOT JUST AFTER THERE WAS AN
ISSUE AS A PATH TO. YOU KNOW
KIND OF HEALING FOR VICTIM AND
FOR THE YOU KNOW THE BETTER LACK
OF A BETTER WORD THE
PERPETRATOR.
BUT THEY ALSO TALKED ABOUT BRING
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE TECHNIQUES
INTO THE TRAINING AND USING THE
TYPES OF. OF MORE FACE TO FACE
AN INTERACTIVE.
TRAINING AS A WAY TO HELP AND
I'M WONDERING IF YOU'VE SEEN
THAT DONE IN LARGE ORGANIZATIONS
AND WHAT YOUR EXPERIENCES AND IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT'S NOW BEING
LOOKED OUT MORE TO COME. AS A
WAY OF MAKING THE TRAINING MORE
VALUABLE.
SO ALL OF OUR TRAINING THAT WE
DO A TRAINING TODAY IS
INTERACTIVE SO ON THE HANDOUTS
THAT WE GAVE JUST GOOD TO
DELIVER TO YOU.
THE AUSSIE PLAYING CARDS ON EACH
SLIDE.
BECAUSE SUPERVISORS HAVE A
TENDENCY TO SIT IN THE BACK WITH
THEIR HEAD DOWN IN THEIR TEXTING
WHILE THEY'RE GOING THROUGH THIS
MANDATED TRAINING THAT THEY ALL
DISLIKES THAT WE FIGURED OUT A
WAY NO YOU HAVE TO ENGAGE IN YOU
HAVE TO. BE PART OF THIS
CONVERSATION.
IN ORDER TO LEARN WHAT WE NEED
TO LEARN AND TAKE IT BACK TO
YOUR WORKPLACE AND ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENT IT.
SO THE PLAYING CARDS MAKE THEM
BE A LITTLE INTERACTIVE BUT IT
ALSO TAKES WHEN THEY FIRST SIT
DOWN IN THE ROOM. THEY SEE THESE
PLAYING CARDS AND IT TAKES.
THE DREARY NESTS OUT OF THE
TRAINING THAT THEY THINK THEY'RE
COMING TO AND MAKES A LITTLE
MORE FUN AND WE HAVE EXPERIENCED
HUGE INTERACTION.
AND A LOT OF CHANGE IN
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
GOING THROUGH THIS TRAINING
TODAY.
THAT I THINK THAT THEY IT
WASN'T SO MUCH THAT IT WAS
INTERACTIVE TO IT WAS A TYPE OF
OF SORT OF EMPATHY TRAINING AND
GETTING AT THE ROOT OF WHAT YOU
KNOW THE TWO OF THE IT.
INTERPERSONAL DYNAMICS THAT
PEOPLE BRING THE THINGS IN A WAY
THAT WAS. NOT SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
ANY. ABOUT ANY KIND OF
HARASSMENT THE WAY THE TYPICAL
SEXUAL HARASSMENT TRAINING IS
BUT REALLY ABOUT MAKING PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND EACH OTHER'S FOR
PERSPECTIVES AND COMMUNICATE
BETTER.
SO AT ON OF THOUGHTS AND HOW DID
THAT DELIVERS THAT CONVERSATION
SO WHEN YOU MAKE IT MORE
INTERACTIVE AND THEY'RE MORE
ENGAGED WE. ARE TRAINING
TYPICALLY WE TELL THEM THAT'S
MANDATED TWO HOURS I HAVE YET IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN TO DO
TRAINING LESS THAN THREE HOURS
BECAUSE OF THEIR QUESTIONS NOT
BECAUSE OF OUR TRAINING.
AND THEY'RE THEY'RE VERY OPEN
ABOUT THEIR CONVERSATIONS WELL
WHAT IF THIS HAPPENED. AND WHAT
IF YOU SAW THIS
AND WE TALK ABOUT IT AND IT
COULD BECOMES MORE REAL TO THEM
BECAUSE IS ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THEIR WORKPLACE
THEY HAVE A POINT OF REFERENCE
THAT THREE.
AND SO IT DOES MAKE A CHANGE.
BUT I THINK YOU HAVE TO BE OPEN
TO ADDRESSING THAT AND I THINK
THAT'S.
PART OF WHERE THE IMPLICIT BIAS
COMES INTO BECAUSE WE HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION WHERE PEOPLE GO.
WELL YOU KNOW THIS HAPPENED AT A
PLACE I WORKED.
YEAH THIS HAPPENED TO A FRIEND
THAT I KNOW AND IT'S THEIR OWN
BIAS IN THERE'D DO IN A CHECK
THEY'RE DOING A SELF TECH LIKE
IS THIS. A MILE IN THE FINE LINE
HERE AND SO IT OPENS UP THAT
CONVERSATION. LIKE I REALLY
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU SAID WHAT
YOU SAID ABOUT MAKING THE
TRAINING RELEVANT TO YOUR
WORKPLACE WE HAVE A PRETTY
UNIQUE WORKPLACE HERE. AND THE
TRAINING THAT THAT WE DO IS NOT
AT ALL UNIQUE TO OUR WORKPLACE
IT'S.
YOU KNOW IT'S VERY DATED AND
IT'S VERY GENERIC AND IT'S YOU
KNOW BOB IN TEEN AT THE WATER
COOLER IN. AND WE HAVE SOME I'M
OFTEN TINA LITERALLY FOUGHT OFF
ROBIN TINA I KNOW THEM.
AND.
YOU KNOW US TRYING TO CREATE
SOMETHING AT LEAST YOU KNOW
MAYBE S. A DIFFERENT TRAINING
FOR MEMBERS THAT REALLY FOCUSES
ON THE TYPE OF EXPERIENCES THAT
WE HAVE THAT'S DIFFERENT AND
PUTTING US IN SOME OF THOSE.
MORE PROBLEMATIC SITUATIONS AND
KIND OF WORKING THIS THROUGH
SOME OF THOSE.
.
SITUATIONS AYE AYE VISITORS
RIFIC IDEA AND I'M VERY GLAD
THAT YOU. YOU KNOW BROUGHT THAT
TO THAT TO THE FOREFRONT OF KIND
OF HOW IRRELEVANT THE TRAINING
IS.
THAT WE HAVE FROM UP FROM A
CONTENT PERSPECTIVE I THINK THAT
THE AYE SPECIFIC ITEMS THAT YOU
MENTIONED ARE REALLY IMPORTANT.
AND THAT'S YOU KNOW WHAT I REFER
TO AS SORT OF MY FIVE ESSENTIALS
OF THE LIBRARY.
IT WILL NECESSARILY INCLUDE
WITHIN THEIR OWN IN
COMMUNICATION BROUGHT TRAINING
FOR EXAMPLE A LEVEL OF
UNDERSTANDING AND EMPATHY SO
THAT LEVEL YOU KNOW RATHER THAN
SEEKING. TO TO CHANGE SOMEONE'S
MIND TO CHANGE THEIR BEHAVIOR TO
REALLY DO THINGS IN A WAY THAT
THE TRAINING. LETS PEOPLE SEE.
THE OTHER SIDE THE POINT LET'S
PEOPLE SEE WHAT ANOTHER PERSON
MIGHT VIEW SO DELIVERING IT IN A
WAY THAT I THINK REALLY FOCUSES
ON THAT EMPATHY. THE TRICK WOULD
BE TO DO IT IN A WAY THAT IS
RELEVANT TO THE WORKPLACE SO THE
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE ISSUES I
THINK ARE.
ANALOGOUS BUT THEY'RE NOT.
IMMEDIATELY ANALOGOUS YOU YOU
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU PUT
THEM IN THE CONTEXT THAT IS
GOING TO BE.
RELEVANT TO THE WORKPLACE THE
OTHER WAY IN WHICH IN ADDITION
TO TRAINING THAT I SEE THE
CONCEPT OF RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
USED REALLY EFFECTIVELY. IS AND
WHAT I CALL WORKPLACE MEDIATIONS
AND SO TO THE EXTENT THAT THERE
IS GOING TO BE.
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE
MECHANISMS ESTABLISH WHETHER
IT'S HERE AT THE LEGISLATURE OR
IN PRIVATE.
ENTITIES HAVING.
AND ON THAT'S PERSON HAVING
SOMEBODY WHO WAS REALLY ABLE TO.
MEDIATE DISPUTES AT AN EARLY
STAGE IS GOING TO BE IMPORTANT
AND I THINK THAT RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE PERSPECTIVE IS IS
IMPORTANT THERE. I WHEN I FIRST
STARTED DOING REPLACE MEDIATIONS
I ACTUALLY HAD A CONVERSATION
WITH A COLLEAGUE OF MINE WHO HAD
BEEN A FEDERAL MAGISTRATE AND
HAD IT WAS NOT DOING PRIVATE
MEDIATIONS. AND THAT HE CAPTURED
PERFECTLY HE SAID YOU KNOW PATTY
WHAT I DO IS TO FORCE A
COUNSELING WHAT YOU DO IS
MARRIAGE COUNSELING.
AND AGAIN WE CAN'T MAKE TOO
MANY ANALOGIES BECAUSE THEY'RE
DIFFERENT RELATIONSHIPS BUT IT
IT RANG TRUE THAT WHAT I'M DOING
IS TRYING TO KEEP PEOPLE
TOGETHER WHEN I'M TRYING TO DO
IS. INCREASE AT LEVEL OF EMPATHY
AND FAIRS REMINDING THAT MEMBERS
COME
I HEAR FROM MANY DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES OUT A LOT OF
MEMBERS HAVE NEVER MANAGED OUT
BEFORE AND WE MAKE THE
ASSUMPTION THAT THEY'RE CAPABLE
OF DOING THAT WITHOUT GIVING
THEM.
THE BACKGROUND THE TRAINING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE YOU
KNOW THAT THEY REALLY UNDERSTAND
WHAT THAT REQUIRES AND AND EVEN
CHIEFS A LOT OF OUR CHIEFS COME
TO US THROUGH CAMPAIGNS THROUGH.
ALL KINDS OF OTHER WORK AND I
THINK THAT OFFERING THAT TO OUR
CHIEFS TO OUR MEMBERS.
IS SOMETHING THAT COULDBE
EXTREMELY VALUABLE HARM TO US
NOT JUST WITH SEXUAL HARASSMENT
BUT HAVING A BETTER FUNCTIONING
WORKPLACE AND TO DISTRICT
DIRECTORS I MEAN I WOULD I WOULD
SAY THAT.
I'VE I'VE YOU KNOW. WHAT IT
WOULD THEY DON'T COME TO THIS
POSITION TO THE NATURAL
SELECTION NATURAL SELECTION
PROCESS THAT OTHER SUPERVISORS
DO OF WORKING THEIR WAY UP THE
RANKS AND HAVING TO DEMONSTRATE
AND LEARN THOSE SKILLS SO I?
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR I'M
HIGHLIGHTING THAT AND BRING THAT
TO US SOME MEMBER WALDRON I
BELIEVE YOU HAD YOUR HAND UP
AND.
WE'LL GO HOME WHERE I THINK YOU
MADAM CHAIR.
.
THANK YOU SO MUCH VERY
INFORMATIVE.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT COME UP
WHEN WE DISCUSS THIS CULTURE
IDEA. WHICH ARM YOU KNOW I THINK
IS REALLY.
THE WAY ULTIMATELY IT'S GONNA
NEED NEED TO BE ADDRESSED.
BOB YOU KNOW I TRY TO VISUALIZE
WHAT WOULD THAT CULTURE BE AND
IT'S YOU KNOW THE TRAINING BUT
THEN EVERYONE WALKS OUT OF
TRAINING AND THEN THERE AND WORK
IT'S KINDA LIKE GOING TO CHURCH
ON SUNDAY AND THEN ON MONDAY YOU
KNOW YOU'RE. WHO TALK ON THE
WORK AND THAT'S ALL FORGOTTEN
BUT?
HOW DO YOU MAINTAIN THAT
CULTURE BECAUSE YOU KNOW I TRY
TO VISUALIZE?
THE WAY OUR LIFESTYLE IS HERE.
YOU KNOW WHEN THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE COMING AND GOING.
SOMETIMES VERY INTENSE
SITUATIONS STRESS.
LOT OF SOCIALIZING A LOT OF YOU
KNOW WORDS GOING AROUND.
TO ME A CULTURE WOULD BE AN
INCIDENT OCCURS MAY BE. A VERY
SLIGHT INCIDENT. BUT.
OTHERPEOPLE STEP IN AND SAY ALL
BACK OFF OR THEY SEE IT LIKE
THERE'S.
A SUPPORT APPEARS AROUND.
I MEAN AND HOW DO YOU.
GET TO THAT POINT BECAUSE
SUSTAINING IN TRAINING IT SO
MUCH MORE AND I KNOW YOU TALKED
ABOUT OF SOME MICHAEL TRAINING
OF THOSE LIKE LITTLE BOOSTERS
SAY. AND HOW OFTEN WOULD THAT
BE.
TO KEEP YOU KNOW TO TRY TO
CREATE AND WE'VE EMPLOYEES
COMMON GOAL ALL THE TIME.
WE HAVE SOME VERY YOUNG STAFF OR
INTERNS THEY'RE ONLY THERE FOR A
FEW MONTHS AND THEN THEY'RE GONE
TOO. IN A BIGGER AND BETTER.
AND THAT'S BEEN SOME OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT WE'VE SEEN SO.
I NEED ALL BE HAPPY TO SHARE AND
WILL WITH WITH JESSICA SOMETHING
THAT WE'VE PUT TOGETHER A COUPLE
OF OF RESOURCES WE PUT TOGETHER
THAT I THINK MIGHT BE REALLY
HELPFUL TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
ONE IS A LOT OF AT LEAST PART OF
CORPORATIONS HAVE BEEN TAKING A
STEP WHICH I THINK IS A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION BUT THEM AND
EXECUTING IT AS WELL AS THEY
SHOULD. OF SENDING A LETTER FROM
THE CEO TO ALL EMPLOYEES SAYING
LOOK WE CARE ABOUT THIS ME TO
SITUATION WE UNDERSTAND WE
REALLY WANNA BE DIFFERENT.
BUT FRANKLY IT'S THE SAME OLD
SAME OLD AND SO IT'S A LETTER
THAT SAYS WE REALLY CARE ABOUT
NOT HAVING UNLAWFUL ARRESTS IN
THE WORKPLACE. HERE'S A COPY OF
OUR POLICY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'VE WRITTEN SENATE TEMPLATE
LETTER THAT SAYS AYE HERE'S THE
PROMISE WE MADE TO YOU AND
HERE'S WHAT WE EXPECT IN RETURN.
WHAT WE PROMISE YOU IS THAT WE
ARE GOING TO TEACH A COMMON
LANGUAGE WHERE WE CAN
COMMUNICATE WITH EACH OTHER IN A
WAY THAT MAKES SENSE?
ONE OF OUR SIGNATURE TOOLS AT
AND TRAIN IS SOMETHING WE CALL
THE WORKPLACE COLOR SPECTRUM AND
IT IS A WAY OF TAKING LEGALLY
CHARGED.
DEFENSIVE OF LANGUAGE THAT
COULD INCREASE THE TEMPERATURE
INSTEAD OF DECREASE SAID AND
BRING IT DOWN TO A LEVEL WHERE
EVERYONE CAN UNDERSTAND IT SO
IT'S LITERALLY A COLOR SPECTRUM
ECHOES FROM GREEN. TO. YELLOW TO
ORANGE TO RED AND A WE GIVE
EXAMPLES WHERE RATHER THAN
SAYING YOU BIG JERK WHAT YOU
JUST SAID WAS SEXIST AND AND
HARASSING YOU SAY. YOU KNOW WHAT
BOB THAT WAS.
ORANGE A COMMENT AND AND IT'S
REALLY SOMETHING THAT IS.
OFFENSIVE TO ME AND PROBABLY TO
OTHERS SO IT NOT ONLY PROVIDES A
REALLY EASY WAY FOR THE PERSON
TO BE ABLE TO.
EXPRESS ANY TYPE OF OF CONCERN
IT ALSO PROVIDES A REALLY EASY
WAY FOR BY SANDERS TO BE ABLE TO
SAY HEY WAIT A MINUTE EVEN IF
THAT PERSON DIDN'T SPEAK UP THAT
WAS A DARK YELLOW YOU KNOW GOING
INTO ORANGE COMMENT. ON THE
OTHER THING THAT WE FOUND THAT
IT DOES IN THIS GOES BACK TO THE
EMBASSIES UNDERSTANDING. IS THAT
WE HAVE FOUND AND ESPECIALLY
VERY VERY SPECIFICALLY ON THE
ISSUE OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT WE
DON'T ALL SEE THE WORLD THE SAME
WAY.
AND SO ME SAYING THAT SOMETHING
IS ORANGE.
THE PERSON WHO MADE THE
STATEMENT MIGHT SAY THAT WAS
GREEN TO ME.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
DISCONNECT IS.
A STATISTIC THAT I OFTEN SITE
IN TERMS OF MY INVESTIGATIONS
ARE CONDUCTED PEOPLE ARE OFTEN
SURPRISED TO KNOW THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THEM. HAD NO FACTUAL
DISPUTE IT WASN'T A HE SAID SHE
SAID SITUATION IT WAS THIS IS
WHAT'S ALLEGED THE PERSON
ACCUSED SAYS YES THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENED.
SO WHAT.
AND IT WAS TRULY JUST A
DIFFERENCE IN PERCEPTION AND IN
UNDERSTANDING OR FEELING WHAT
ONE PERSON FELT WAS APPROPRIATE
THE OTHER FELT WAS
INAPPROPRIATE.
SO YOU KNOW CREATING A COMMON
LANGUAGE HAVING TOOLS THAT GO
BEYOND JUST YOUR POLICY THE TALK
ABOUT.
PAT BUT THE UNLAWFUL CONDUCT.
I THINK SLOWLY OVER TIME WITH
ALL OF THESE THINGS PUT INTO
PLACE OF THE MICRO LEARNING
LESSONS WOULD WE'VE BEEN WORKING
ON A NEED TO CAMPAIGN FOR
EXAMPLE THAT ADDRESSES EACH
CONSTITUENCY. SO THE FIRST VIDEO
THAT WE PUT OUT A VERY SHORT TWO
MINUTE VIDEO THAT WENT OUT TO.
ALL OF OUR.
OUR AUDIENCE WAS INTRODUCING
THIS CONCEPT OF A LOT OF THE
THINGS THAT I TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER. THE NEXT ONE WAS WHAT
IF ON A TARGET AND IT'S OFFERING
ACTUAL PRACTICAL LANGUAGE A
SCRIPT FOR WHAT YOU MIGHT SAY IF
YOU WERE EXPOSED MISCONDUCT. AND
THEN A HANDOUT THAT SAYS IF
YOU'RE NOT COMFORTABLE DEALING
WITH IT YOURSELF WHEN YOU GO TO
A CHARTER SAY THIS NOT THAT.
SO WOULD ACTUALLY AGAIN
DECREASES THE TEMPERATURE. WE'VE
ANOTHER VIDEO AT A DESK
ADDRESSES WHAT IF YOU'RE A
BYSTANDER HERE SOME VERY
PRACTICAL UP WORDSTHAT YOU CAN
ACTUALLY USE TO ACTUALLY DEFUSE
A SITUATION. WHAT IF I'VE BEEN
ACCUSED?
AGAIN ALL VERY PRACTICAL
INFORMATION ON WAYS THAT YOU CAN
AVOID BEING ACCUSED IN THE FIRST
PLACE AND WHAT TO DO IF YOU ARE
ACCUSED. I'M AN ATTORNEY BUT ONE
OF THE THINGS I SAY IS HOW PUT
YOU APOLOGIZE.
THERE'S SOMETHING THAT YOU CAN
DO.
SO REALLY I THINK OFFERING A
VARIETY OF WAYS IN WHICH
EVERYTHING POINTS.
TO THE SAME DIRECTION WHICH IS
IMPROVING THE CULTURE. IT
TRICKLES DOWN AND EVERYTHING
ELSE JUST SORT OF FALLS INTO
PLACE.
I MEAN BECAUSE ONE YOU KNOW
HEREABOUTS THE.
SOME OF THE VICTIMS THAT HAVE
COME FORWARD.
THEA YOU KNOW JUST THE STRENGTH
IT TOOK TO DO THAT BECAUSE THEY
WERE JUST LEAVING IT ALONE I
MEAN THERE WAS NO PEER SUPPORT
HER HINAULT. THAT STOOD UP FOR
THEM AND THEY WERE ACTUALLY IN A
WAY ISOLATED.
SO YOU KNOW WE REALLY WANTED TO
THE OFFICES.
AND ESPECIALLY WHEN WE CONSIDER
IT YOU KNOW THE POWER SITUATION
THAT'S PERCEIVED IN ONLY OF WHAT
THE SENATOR SAY WORLD FOOD
SUMMIT PERSON AND. YOU KNOW AN
INTERN OR A YOUNG PERSON AND
THINGS OCCUR AND STAFF PEOPLE
AROUND MIGHT SEE BUT THAT WHO'S
GOING TO STEP IN AND I THINK.
EMPOWERING THE VICTIM.
NO IN A WAY. THAT THE PEER OVER
THERE AND THEY STEP IN ONE THE
OTHER ONE CAN FOR EVERYONE LIKE
YOU'RE SAYING THE CULTURE.
STARTS TO GROW SO THEY
UNDERSTAND THOSE LEVELS OF YOU
KNOW WHAT LEVEL WAS THAT.
STEP IN.
AND THAT PREVENTS IT FROM
ESCALATING TO A POINT WHERE THEN
WE REALLY HAVE.
YOU KNOW THE SITUATION.
SO BUT I JUST JUST ONE QUICK
OTHER RUN.
YOU TALK ABOUT DATA AND YOU
KNOW HAVING DATA WHAT TYPES OF
DATA WOULD.
WE LOOK TO COLLECT FROM TO
IMPLEMENT THAT KIND OF DATA
DRIVEN PROGRAM.
WEALTH I CAN TELL YOU ABOUT
WHAT WHAT ARE OR APPROACHES THE
WATER SOLUTION IS.
AND IN OUR.
IN OUR CURRENT TRAINING
PLATFORMS WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
VERY ROBUST
Q. AND A SECTION WHERE SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS ACTUALLY RECEIVE.
REAL LIFE QUESTIONS FROM THE
LEARNERS AND WERE ABLE TO ANSWER
THEM IN A. ACCURATE BUT BUT ALSO
VERY PRACTICAL WAY. AND WE ARE
ABLE TO THEN COLLECT DATA ON THE
TYPES OF QUESTIONS ARE BEING
ASKED HOW MUCH TIME PEOPLE ARE
SPENDING ON THE QUEUE IN A
SECTION. HOW MUCH TIME THEY'RE
SPENDING ON DIFFERENT PARTS OF
THE TRAINING SESSION AND IT'S
REALLY VERY VERY INFORMATIVE IN
TERMS OF?
POTENTIAL BLIND SPOTS WHERE YOU
KNOW THINGS MIGHT BE GOING AWRY.
WE HAVE AN UNCONSCIOUS BIAS
TRAINING COURSE THAT ASKS THEM
REALLY REALLY FASCINATING
POLLING UESTIONS AND IN THE END
RESULT IN A IN A DATA ANALYTICS
REPORT THAT SAYS THINGS LIKE.
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF YOUR
EMPLOYEES FEEL LIKE THEY BELONG
IN YOUR?
INDUSTRY OR EXCUSE ME IN YOUR
COMPANY.
IT HAS.
SOME COMMENTS THAT WE AGGREGATE
AND SAY YOU KNOW WE SEE A
PATTERN OF.
ALL SHARE ONE WITH YOU THAT WE
DID RECENTLY WITH A CLIENT WHERE
WE SAY YOU KNOW SIX DIFFERENT
WOMEN SAY THAT THEY FEEL LIKE
THEY'RE NOT HEARD DURING
MEETINGS DESPITE THE FACT THAT
THEIR LEADERS. THAT'S A TREND
THAT WE NEED TO WATCH FOR.
WE ARE COMING OUT WITH A NEW
SOLUTION.
A TECHNOLOGICAL SOLUTION THAT'S
REALLY GOING TO TAKE THAT THE
NEXT STEP.
TO AGGREGATE ISSUES RELATED TO
Q. IN A SO THAT WE CAN THEN
SHARE THAT WITH EMPLOYERS TO
AGAIN SAY HERE'S AREAS THAT YOU
REALLY NEED TO BE CONCERNED WITH
THAT WHETHER THAT MEANS
INCREASED TRAINING IN THAT AREA
WHETHER THAT MEANS PAYING
ATTENTION. THEREARE DEFINITELY
WAYS THAT AGAIN FOR ME IT'S THAT
IDEA OF CREATING A POSITIVE
VICIOUS CYCLE NOW YOU'VE GOT
PEOPLE WHO ARE ADDRESSING THINGS
EARLY. THEY'RE GETTING TAKEN
CARE OF THEY FEEL TRUSTS OF IT
THEY CAN REPORT THOSE THINGS AND
IN THE EVENT THAT SOMETHING
SLIPS THROUGH THE CRACKS.
THERE'S STILL COMFORTABLE
REPORTING IT GETS INVESTIGATED
FAIRLY GETS RESOLVED AND THE
CYCLE CONTINUES.
ADAM WARLOCK.
BETTER.
BUT MISTER FINO YOU YOU PROVIDED
US WITH A. HAND OUT WITH SLIDES
AND.
HE FOUND ON SLIDE THREE OF PAGE
ONE YOU REFERRED TO THE
CALIFORNIA'S.
PAMPHLET SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
WHO PRINTS THAT? FAMILY AT THE
AGE.
AND.
DO YOU HAVE A A COPY OF IT WITH
YOU I DO NOT.
WHERE WOULD ONE GET THAT?
THE FE H. WITH THING I'D ADD ON
THE WEBSITE. THAT WE RECEIVED
THAT AT ALL AS MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
HAVE YOU RECEIVED THAT ALREADY
OKAY.
SO IN BUSINESS IT'S REQUIRED
THAT EVERY NEW EMPLOYEE RECEIVE
THAT.
OKAY UPON HIGHER. BUT I'VE HIGH
WILL LOOK THAT UP YOU ALSO ON
PAGE THREE HAVE.
A SLIDE.
THE NUMBER SO TINY AND MIGHT BE
IN EIGHT.
.
ARE THERE OTHER CALIFORNIA
PUBLICATIONS REFERRED TO.
TWO THOUSAND FIVE A SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PREVENTION TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS FROM. FROM THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA RIGHT SO
THESE ARE NOT.
DOCUMENTS THAT WERE REFERRING
TO THESE OF THE LAWS WHEN THEY
CAME INTO EFFECT.
ON THE SLIDE QUE SO YOU'RE JUST
TELLING THEM THERE'S THIS LAW
THAT WE WERE THE FIRST SECTION
THAT WE COVER IS THE BASIC
FOUNDATION OF THE LAWS OF WHY WE
HAVE.
THIS CLASS WAY WE ARE HERE. YOU
KNOW HERE'S WHAT YOU NEED TO
COMPLY WITH SO WE HAVE TO COVER
THAT IT'S MANDATED IN PART OF
THE TRAINING.
THE HACKER NO LIFE FIRST AB
EIGHTEEN TWENTY FIVE WHO WHO
THAT'S THE LAW YOU'RE REFERRING
TO THE FACT.
AND WOULD THAT LAW AND ALL THAT
BE IN SIDE THIS SEXUAL
HARASSMENT. PAMPHLET THAT COMES
ON THE WEBSITE. YEAH SO THAT IF
HE AGE PAMPHLET I MEAN.
IT'S KIND OF LIKE THE HOW TO SUE
YOUR HEART.
SO IT'S THEIR RIGHTS IT'S A
NOTICE OF THEIR RIGHTS AND IF
THEY HAVE A COMPLAINT THAT THEY
CAN COMPLAIN TO THE DEVIATION
HOW THEY FILE A COMPLAINT.
AND THEN YOU REFERRED TO THE
PLAYING CARDS ON SLIDE HIM.
SO WHAT WHAT DOES THAT MEAN I I
HADN'T HEARD OF THAT BEFORE SO
WHAT WE DO IS WE LITERALLY PASS
OUT CARDS.
EVERY PARTICIPANT HAS AT LEAST
TWO OR THREE CARDS DEPENDING ON
THE NUMBER OF THE PEOPLE IN THE
ROOM.
AND WHEN YOUR CARD COMES UP ON
THE SLIDE SO THEY DON'T SEE THAT
THE WHOLE SLIDE THE BEGINNING WE
ASK THE QUESTIONS AND AND IT
BECOMES A VERY LIVELY AND AND
KIND OF INTERACTIVE TRAINING
PROCESS BUT THEY LEARN FROM IT.
AND THEY SHARE THEIR OWN STORIES
WHICH MAKES IT MORE REAL.
PHILIP I HAVE THE KING OF
HEARTS.
IN MY HAND YOU'RE GOING TO CALL
ON ME THE INNER.
YOU ARE OKAY OKAY. SO JUST.
YOU KNOW ONE. THING YEAHBUT NO
I. I JUST I'M JUST TRYING TO I'M
JUST TRYING TO GET IT.
.
WHAT IS YOUR OPINION OF CLIMATE
SURVEYS?
I THINK THEY'RE USEFUL.
.
BUT YOU HAVE TO TAKE IN THE
CONTEXT THE PERSONALITIES IN THE
WORK ENVIRONMENT TO AND SURVEYS
ARE JUST LIKE ANYTHING ELSE
PEOPLE SAY WHAT THEY THINK
SOMETIMES YOU WANTED THEM TO SAY
SO IMPLICIT BIAS. IS A GOOD
EXAMPLE WHEN WE ASK PEOPLE
THINGS ALSO AND I WOULD NEVER DO
THAT.
AND THEN THEY DO IT.
IT'S NOT BECAUSE THEY THINK
THEY'RE NEVER GONNA DO THAT THEY
DON'T KNOW THAT THAT IS THEIR
BIAS.
IT'S REALLY UNCONSCIOUS AND IT'S
BURIED VERY DEEPLY SO IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT THEY.
WOULD. NECESSARILY SAYING OH
YEAH DOUBTS WOMEN BE SO WHEN YOU
DO ALL THE DATA YES THE DATA IS
HELPFUL BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO
ADDRESS THE PERSONALITY OF THAT.
INDIVIDUAL ORGANIZATION SO TO
PATTY'S POINT WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
WHO IT IS WHERE TRAINING.
WHEN I DO SEXUAL HARASSMENT
TRAINING FOR HOT AGENCY THEIR
CRAZY PEOPLE THERE FUND IN THEIR
CREATIVE AND THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY THEY HAVE TO HAVE
RULES.
IT'S REALLY JUST.
THE OPPOSITE OF HOW THEY WORK.
AND IF I GO INTO A BANK AND I DO
IT THEY'RE ALL ABOUT RULES.
SO THEN I ADDRESS IT DIFFERENTLY
SO WE HAVE TO SPEAK DIFFERENTLY
TO THE DIFFERENT. AUDIENCE IF
YOU WILL THAT WE ARE TRAINING.
THE DOUBT IS HELPFUL BECAUSE
THEN WE KNOW IS THE TRAINING
BEING EFFECTIVE.
DO WE SEE A CHANGE IN THE NUMBER
OF COMPLAINTS THAT WERE GETTING.
ARE PEOPLE ACTUALLY CHANGING THE
CULTURE ARE WE HEARING LESS AND
LESS ABOUT OWN MAN THIS BOX THAT
I WORK FOR.
AND YES I THINK IT IS A VERY
DIFFERENT ENVIRONMENT THAT YOU
HAVE HERE BECAUSE OF THE COMINGS
AND GOINGS OF PEOPLE BECAUSE.
OF LITTLE ELECTED VERSUS HIRED.
TYPE OF OF STAFF THAT YOU HAVE
SO. YOU HAVE TO ADDRESS THAT TO
THE DATA IS DEFINITELY HELPFUL
FROM YOUR LEVEL BECAUSE.
IT IT.
GIVE SOME FOUNDATIONAL.
REASONING FOR WHY WE DO WHAT WE
DO BT IT CAN'T BE EXCLUSIVE OF
ANYTHING ELSE.
YOU DO IT AT THE BEGINNING AND
THEN MAYBE ABOUT SIX MONTHS
LATER TO SEE IF THERE'S BEEN A.
IMPROVED.
CLIMATE CHANGE I GUESS WOULD BE
THE. SO MOST OF OUR CLIENTS
RETURNS BUT.
BUT THAT HAVE THEY BEHAVED
BETTER.
MOST OUR CLIENTS ACTUALLY READ
THEY RETAIN S. JUST TO DO THE
HARASSMENT TRAINING AND THEN
AFTER THE TRAINING IS DONE THEY
RETAIN THIS OF CONSULTANTS.
SO WE HAVE AN ONGOING
RELATIONSHIP WITH THEM TO HELP
COACH AND COUNSEL THEM INTO THAT
BETTER BEHAVIOR. AND I THINK
THAT'S REALLY KEY YOU CAN TRAIN
ALL DAY LONG.
BUT YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO DO
FOLLOW THROUGH AND THAT MEANS
THAT CULTURE HOUSE TO START
BEING IN PLACE. THAT PEOPLE ARE
ONCE THEY'VE BEEN TRAINED NOT
AFRAID TO SAY YOU KNOW WHAT
THAT'S NOT RIGHT PLEASE DON'T
SAY THAT DON'T DO THAT.
AND THAT THEIR PEERS AROUND THEM
CAN CALL PEOPLE OUT AND IT'S SO
IT HAS TO GO HAND IN HAND I
DON'T SEE HOW IT WORKS IF IT
DOESN'T.
WHISPERS DO YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS ON CLIMATE SURVEYS.
I'M LOOKING DIFFERENT AD I
THINK THAT.
THAT THAT IDEA OF IT BEING A
SNAPSHOT AND KIND OF YOU KNOW
YOUR BASELINE YOU START FROM
THERE AND THEN SEEING IF THERE
ARE.
CHANGES THAT MAKE I THINK
THEY'RE THEY'RE.
AS GOOD AS THEIR DEVELOPMENT SO
IF THE QUESTIONS ARE GOOD YOU
KNOW DATA IN GOOD DEAD IN WILL
PRODUCE GOOD DEBT OUT.
SO.
YOU MENTIONED IN YOUR INTRO
THAT YOU HAD DONE SO MANY
INVESTIGATIONS THAT THE
MAJORITY.
OF VICTIMS WERE FEMALES.
MAJORITY OF PERPETRATORS FOR
MALES. I'M DO YOU HAVE OR HAVE
YOU.
BUILT A.
A OUT A PORTFOLIO OF VICTIM
CHARACTERISTICS.
THAT THERE ARE SOME I THINK
THERE IS A. AND NOT I'M NOT A
PSYCHOLOGIST BY TRADE BUT I FEEL
LIKE I PLAY ONE ON TV. AND THERE
ARE SOME.
CHARACTERISTICS THAT I DID SEE
BOTH END OF THE VICTIMS AND IN
SOME CASES IN THE PERPETRATORS.
YOU KNOW NOT TO THE POINT WHERE
I CAN TELL YOU WITH WITH
PSYCHOLOGICAL PRECISION. BUT THE
ONE THAT I MENTIONED I THINK IS
THE MOST IMPORTANT ONE WHICH IS
THAT.
DIFFERENCE IN POWER CREATING A
DISCOMFORT.
OF FEAR.
A CONCERN OF YOU KNOW WHERE I
MIGHT GET A REPORT IT NOW BE
VIEWED AS A TROUBLEMAKER WHO'S
GONNA BELIEVE ME ANYWAY BECAUSE
THIS PERSON IS MORE POWERFUL
THAN I AM.
I DON'T HAVE ANY WITNESSES IT'S
ALL GONNA BE HE SAID SHE SAID.
SO ALL OF THESE ISSUES THAT
THAT COME TO MIND THERE'S NOT
NECESSARILY ONLY ONE TYPE OF
WOMAN BUT I THINK THOSE ARE THE
COMMON FEELINGS THAT THEY HAVE
THAT MIGHT.
MAKE THEM RELUCTANT TO COME
FORWARD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VENTURE.
AS A MEMBER DALY.
THAT SHARE. THE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY I.
ONE OF PAINT A PICTURE FOR YOU
SO.
I'VE BEEN HERE SINCE TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE. AND I'VE BEEN
TO I WAS ELECTED SIXTEEN YEARS
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT BEFORE AND
SERVE. ATTENDED MANY.
THE TRAININGS.
MORE THAN I WANT TO THINK I HAD
TO GO TO.
BUT THE DYNAMICS OF THIS
BUILDING AND. SO I WANT TO SHARE
WITH YOU KNOW I ONE OF FRAME
THIS IN A WAY THAT. WE WILL MAKE
SOME SENSE.
INTO IN.
BUT EARLIER DEBEERS HERE NOT
RECENTLY BUT THERE WAS SO
THERE'S LEGISLATION THAT COMES
THROUGH HERE SO THERE WAS
LEGISLATION THAT. WAS PUTTING
REGULATION ON THE ADULT FILM
INDUSTRY.
ON.
PROTECTIONS.
AND THERE WAS GRAPHIQUE VERY
GRAPHIQUE INFORMATION THAT WAS
FLOATING AROUND THIS BUILDING
THESE CHAMBERS.
IT'S WERE IN AN ENVIRONMENT
WHERE WE HAVE SITUATIONS COME TO
US THAT ARE NOT NORMAL THINGS
THAT WOULD HAPPEN IN AND BEEN.
GOD. MY SEED COMPANY HOME RIGHT
BECAUSE WE WOULD NOT BE
DEBATING.
WHAT ADULT FILMMAKERS SHOULD BE
USING FOR PROTECTIONS?
LIKEWISE PEOPLE IN PRISON WHAT
THEY SHOULD BE.
OBSERVERS SEVERAL BILLS GOING
THROUGH IN IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN.
FOURTEEN I CAN'T REMEMBER WHAT
IT WAS BUT ABOUT THE CURRENT THE
EAST AND IT SO YOU HAVE STAFF
THAT'S YOU'RE WORKING WITH THAT
ANALYZING THESE BILLS. YOU HAVE
MEMBERS FROM. TRYING TO GET
THEIR BILLS PASSED.
SO PUTS US IN A IN A DIFFICULT
WORK ENVIRONMENT AND AND SOME
CASES WHERE. THINGS YOU WOULDN'T
I'M SURE YOU WOULDN'T SEE EVEN
IN YOUR LINE OF WORK FOR YOUR
TRAINING EVERYDAY PHYSICISTS AB
I MAYBE YOU HAVE.
SO WHAT MY QUESTION IS.
HOW DO YOU CHECK HOW DO YOU SET
US UP FOR SUCCESS?
IN AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE IT ISN'T
THE NORM IT ISN'T SOME THINGS
JUST AREN'T THE NORM HERE AND WE
WORK WITH OUR.
COLLEAGUES AND OUR STAFF IN.
SITUATIONS WHERE THEY'RE
UNCOMFORTABLE THINGS YET TO.
REVIEW AND TALK ABOUT BECAUSE
YOU'RE GONNA BE MAKE THE
DECISION ON THOSE THOSE VOTES.
THE OTHER THING DE THE SECOND
QUESTION TWO IS THAT I WANTED TO
ASK AND I'VE ASKED THIS ALMOST.
EVERY PANEL THAT WE'VE HAD.
THE LEGISLATURE.
THERE'S BLOGS THAT YOU TALKED
ABOUT THAT AND THEN PASSED IN
THE LEGISLATURE DOESN'T. BLUFF
ALWAYS.
THE.
WE WE DON'T HERB BUT WHEN IT WE
DON'T CONFORM TO LAWS WE PASS
SOME EVEN EXAMPLE.
WE DON'T PAY TIME AND A HALF
WHEN WE WORK OVER EIGHT HOURS
FOR OUR EMPLOYEES.
AND IT'S.
BEEN SOMETHING THAT I HAVE
PERSONALLY THOUGHT WAS.
KIND OF CRAZY I HAVE TO ABIDE BY
THESE LAWS A HOME BUT I DON'T
HAVE TO ABIDE BY THESE LAWS HERE
AND WE PASS LAWS THAT WE DON'T
HAVE TO. ABIDE BY WHICH MAKES NO
SENSE TO ME.
IF IT'S GOOD FOR.
EVERYBODY ELSE IN CALIFORNIA I
THINK SOMEONE SHOULD BE GOOD
HERE AND THEN MAYBE SOME OF THE.
PEOPLE WHO PASSED LAWS IN OUR
STEAD HELPED SOMETIMES ARE
DIFFICULT TO ACHIEVE.
SO.
WHERE YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT DID
YOU THINK THAT THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD?
HAVE TO CONFORM TO THE LAWS
THAT WE PASS AND NUMBER TWO HOW
WOULD YOU TRAIN.
OR OF PUT INTO PRACTICE WHAT WE
HAVE PIECES OF LEGISLATION TO
COME THROUGH THERE JUST REALLY
DIFFICULT.
A.
THANKS TO BEAVAN TALKING ABOUT
THE FIRST PLACE.
WELL TALK THE FIRST ONE THE ONE
THAT THE SECOND ONE.
WELL I KNOW THIS IS GOOD NEWS
OR BAD NEWS BUT I BET YOU I'VE
SEEN MORE GRAPHIC STUFF AND YOU
HAVE.
TWELVE HUNDRED WORKPLACE
INVESTIGATIONS I HAVE VIDEOS
THAT I HAVE TO WATCH THAT STILL
BECAUSE MY EYES TO BURN JUST
FROM THE MEMORY OF THAT.
THE STUFF THAT GOES ON IN THE
WORKPLACES IS PRETTY INCREDIBLE.
SO I I AM VERY FAMILIAR WITH AND
AS FOR FOURTEEN YEARS I ACTUALLY
OWNED AND OPERATED. A MALE
CONSULTING COMPANY WHERE DID THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THIS WORK AND
SO IN MY INTERVIEW PROCESS I
ACTUALLY HAD TO SIT DOWN WITH. A
POSSIBLE LEGAL ASSISTANCE
POSSIBLE ADMINISTRATIVE
ASSISTANTS AND SAY.
PART OF YOUR JOB IS GOING TO BE
TO DO POINT SEARCHES FOUND PART
OF YOUR JOB IS GOING TO BE TO
THE WEBSITES THAT ARE VERY.
ENOUGH DISTASTEFUL AND AND THAT
MIGHT INSULT YOU.
SO VERY FAMILIAR WITH THAT I'VE
ALSO I'M DELIGHTED TRAINING
SESSIONS A LOT OF CONSULTING
WITH OF WHERE THIS COULD THIS
QUESTION COMES UP WHEN IT COMES
TO MIND IS A. GENTLEMAN CAME UP
TO ME AFTER TRAINING AND SAID I
WORK FOR AN AMBULANCE COMPANY SO
PART OF MY JOB IS TO BE EXPOSED
TO REALLY GORY STUFF AND SO. BY
NECESSITY OF MEN HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT SEXUAL STUFF.
I DON'T KNOW HOW HE QUITE MADE
THAT CONNECTION BUT IT LEADS ME
TO KIND OF THE TWO POINTS I
THINK A REALLY IMPORTANT. ONE IS
THAT THERE IS A REALITY THAT
THERE IS.
A NECESSARY COMPONENT OF A JOB
THAT NEEDS TO JUST BE ADDRESSED
EARLY ON SO JUST LIKE I WOULD
SAY TO MY POTENTIAL CANDIDATES
YOU'RE GOING TO BE EXPOSED TO
SOME UNSEEMLY STUFF YOU KNOW
THAT'S PART OF THE JOB. I THINK
IT'S JUST IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE
YOU SET THOSE EXPECTATIONS. THE
SECOND PART THOUGH I THINK IS
THE MUCH MORE IMPORTANT PART
WHICH IS.
YOUDON'T THAT YOU STILL HAVE TO
WORK WITHIN THE CONFINES OF
PROFESSIONALISM AND RESPECT
SO WHEN THE GENTLEMAN SAID TO ME
YOU KNOW WHEN I SORT OF
PROSELYTISM Y. SAID I TOTALLY
UNDERSTAND YOU WORK FOR AN
AMBULANCE COMPANY POLY UP TO SEE
REALLY GORY STUFF. BUT EXPLAINED
TO ME HOW THAT GOES INTO SEXUAL
CONTENT WELL YOU KNOW IF WE HAVE
TO STRIP SOMEONE MAKE IT I MEAN
WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT THEIR
BODY PARTS.
HOW WAS THAT RELATED TO YOUR
WORK AS YOU KNOW AN EMT WHAT'S
NOT BUT I'M JUST SAYING IT
HAPPENS WILL YOU ANSWER THE
QUESTION IT'S NOT? AND SO IT'S
TAKING THAT STEP FURTHER SO
BEING EXPOSED TO YOU KNOW ISSUES
IN THE ADULT INDUSTRY.
FILM INDUSTRY MIGHT BE ONE
THING SITTING AROUND AND
LAUGHING ABOUT PICTURES IS A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT THING SO I
THINK MAKING SURE THAT YOU
MAINTAIN THAT.
THEORY VERY CLEAR AND AND THICK
LINE BETWEEN THOSE TWO THINGS IS
IMPORTANT. THE SECOND AND THIS
IS CERTAINLY WHAT I DID IN MY
OWN PRACTICE.
IS BEING VERY RESPECTFUL AND SO
I DIVIDED UP CERTAIN THINGS THAT
WERE NECESSARY IN SOME THAT
WEREN'T AND ONE VERY SPECIFIC
EXAMPLE THAT COMES TO MIND AS I
HAD A. YOUNG LADY WHO CAME TO
WORK WITH ME AS A LEGAL
ASSISTANT WOULD VERY VERY DEEP
RELIGIOUS CONVICTIONS THAT MADE
HER EXTREMELY UNCOMFORTABLE. SO
I CARVED SOME THINGS OUT OF HER
JOB DUTIES THAT WERE NOT
COMPLETELY NECESSARY.
THAT OTHER PEOPLE WERE HAPPY TO
DO.
JUST OUT OF RESPECT FOR YOU CAN
STILL DO THE JOB YOU JUST WILL
HAVE TO VISIT A PORN SITE OR YOU
WON'T HAVE TO LOOK AT SOME
THINGS THAT. LIKE I SAID
UNFORTUNATELY IN MY LINE OF WORK
ARE AN EVERYDAY OCCURRENCE.
LIKE A PART TO.
WELL YOU'RE VOTERS WOULD
PROBABLY SAY YES YOU HAVE TO
FOLLOW THE SAME LAWS WE DO.
IS YOU KNOW THE THING IS THIS
IT AS I TELL A LOT OF MY CLIENTS
YOUR POLICIES HAVE TO MAKE
SENSE.
SO WHATEVER POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES YOU PUT IN PLACE THEY
HAVE TO MAKE SENSE FOR THE WORK
THAT YOU DO IN THE WORKPLACE
YOU'RE IN.
NOT EVERYBODY'S GOING TO HAVE
THE SAME RULES IF YOU WILL. AND.
AND I THINK THAT'S KEY IS THAT
YOU HAVE TO STILL WORK WITHIN
THE CONSTRAINTS OF.
WHAT IS NORMALLY DECENT?
TO PATTY'S POINT. YEAH IF YOU
CAN IF YOU HAVE THE ABILITY TO
CARVE THINGS OUT WHERE SOMEONE
WHO IS UNCOMFORTABLE IN A
SITUATION.
CANNOT BE IN THAT SITUATION IT
IN CAN DO SOMETHING ELSE GREAT.
IF YOU DON'T.
THEN YOU KNOW IT'S IT BECOMES A
BIGGER PROBLEM AND THEN IS THAT
PERSON.
SOMEHOW. PUSHED OFF TO A
DIFFERENT POSITION SOMEWHERE
ELSE OR LET GO WELCOME
ALTOGETHER. THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT HAS TO BE DECIDED AND I
AGREE WITH WHAT PATTY SAID.
YOU CAN HAVE CONVERSATIONS THAT
ARE UNCOMFORTABLE AND YOU CAN
ANALYZE THINGS ARE UNPLEASANT.
WITHOUT MAKING IT THE JOKE OF
THE DAY. AND STARTING TO MAKE
THOSE THE UNCOMFORTABLE REMARKS
AFTERWARDS.
AND THAT'S WHERE CROSSES THE
LINE IF IT'S BUSINESS ITS
BUSINESS.
I'VE SEEN MY FAIR SHARE OF
HORRID THINGS IN HARASSMENT
INVESTIGATIONS AND THEY'RE NOT
PLEASANT AND I'VE WATCHED VIDEOS
WHERE SOMEONE THAT HE WAS
INCREDIBLY IN LOVE WITH THE GIRL
AT ANOTHER COMPANY. ANY CENTER
INAPPROPRIATE VIDEOS AND WE GOT
TO WATCH HIM FOR LIKE THE FIRST
TWENTY SECONDS I DIDN'T NEED TO
SEE MORE.
BUT IF THE EXTENSION OF THAT IS
TO MAKE OUR HEARTS ABOUT HIS
BODY PARTS OR TO MAKE JOKES
ABOUT.
HIS AMOROUS INTENTIONS WITH HER
THAT'S WHERE THE LINE IS
CROSSED.
THAT'S WHERE YOU CREATE A
CULTURE OF THIS IS BUSINESS AND
WE STOPPED THERE.
BOB APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS I I
WAS MORE HEADING TOWARDS I GET
THAT WE SHOULD CARVE OUT AND WE
WERE TO PROTECT.
ANYBODY WHO. IS NOT COMFORTABLE
IN ANY SITUATION. BUT WHAT I'M
ASKING YOU AT SOME POINT THIS
COMMITTEES GONNA GIVE
SUGGESTIONS TO. THE REST OF THE
THAT BOTH HOUSES AND OF IT WILL
COME UP WITH SOME GOOD POLICY.
IN.
CRAFTING TRAINING IS WHAT I MATT
MY POINT WAS ON THAT IS THERE.
SUITED NO THE X. DIFFERENT KINDS
OF CIRCUMSTANCES A COME FORWARD
HERE IS A IS KIND LIKE THE
AIMLESS SIXTEEN SITUATION WE
HAVE WE'RE GOING TO SEE
LEGISLATION THAT IS.
GIVE ME A CUP OF OR SOME.
BUT WE NEED TO BUILD A TRAIN
THEM BEFORE WE GET TO THAT
PROCESS THAT HE WOULD
LEGISLATION GIVES YOU THAT'S.
BUT YOU DON'T WORK OUT WITH YOU
NEED A LOT SOMEBODY KNOW THAT
THIS IS GONNA BE A COUPLE OF AND
I THINK THAT'S WHAT MORE I WAS
HEADING IS THAT CAN WE PUT IT.
IT TOGETHER SOMETHING THAT WILL
WORK FOR THIS THIS LINE OF WORK
DEAD ATTACKS THE. VICTIMS AND
AND THE FOLKS THAT SO WE DON'T
GET IN THAT POSITION WHICH IN UP
FRONT.
WHAT TECHNIQUE THAT THAT I HAVE
FOUND TO BE REALLY EFFECTIVE ON
AN ISSUE THAT SPECIFIC?
IS TO PRESENT TO EXTREME.
EXAMPLES THAT I THINK REALLY
HIGHLIGHT. THE ULTIMATE POINT
YOU'RE TRYING TO MAKE SOLVE I'LL
GIVE YOU ONE EXAMPLE THAT'S NOT
EXACTLY RELATED TO WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING BUT I GET ASKED A LOT
PARTICULAR BY MEN. ABOUT
COMPLIMENTS YOU KNOW CAN I EVER
GIVE A COMPLIMENT TO SOMEONE SO
HERE'S HOW I TRAIN ON THAT I SAY
OKAY LISTEN TO TWO EXAMPLES OF
ANY GIVE YOU.
PATTY BICU WHO LOOKS REALLY
NICE TODAY TO DID YOU GET A CUT.
THAT'S ONE.
WELL PATTI THAT DRESS LOOKS
AWESOME ON YOU REALLY SHOWS OFF
HER CURVES.
THEY'RE BOTH COMPLIMENTS.
ONE IS OKAY ONE ISN'T.
SO SIMILARLY I THINK THAT
THERE'S WAYS THAT YOU CAN SAY.
LOOK IN TRAINING THEY'RE GONNA
BE SOME TOPICS THAT ARE GOING TO
BE NECESSARILY INVOLVING.
SEXUAL. ACTIVITIES.
THAT'S ONE SCENARIO. THE OTHER
ONE WOULD BE COOL. CHECK OUT
THIS VIDEO WAY HEY COME OVER
HERE LET'S WATCH IT.
I'VE FOUND THAT DOING THAT IN
TRAINING KIND O DOING BOTH
EXTREMES MAKES PEOPLE GO. ALL I
GET IT.
CUT OUT.
AND DEBATE.
THANK YOU HOME THANK YOU BOTH
AND YOU HAVE A YOU BOTH HAVE
VERY IMPRESSIVE RESUMES.
I GUESS WHERE I AM WITH SO WHERE
WAS BEEN THROUGH OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL MONTHS IS THAT.
STILL VERY FRUSTRATING TO KNOW
WHAT DIRECTION WE'RE GONNA TAKE
AS A COMEDIAN.
HEARING OF WHAT WE'VE LEARNED
HERE WITH THEM SO THAT WE CAN
CRAFT A POLICY. OUR POLICY
STARTED WITH ZERO TOLERANCE
NOBODY BASICALLY UNDERSTOOD WHAT
IS THAT MEAN YOU KNOW IF YOU
MAKE A. COMMENT CHAU DISLIKE YOU
LOOK GREAT IN THAT DRESSING YOUR
CURVES IS ABOUT SOMETHING
BETWEEN PEERS IN THE SAME
OFFICE.
WHERE'S THAT FROM A SUPERVISOR
TO A SUBORDINATE
IT'S A DIFFERENT SITUATION.
SO THE SUPERVISOR HAS TO REPORT
YOU REPORT TO YOUR SUPERVISOR
YOU KNOW JIM SAID THAT TO ME AND
I'M OFFENDED THEN THE SUPERVISOR
HAVE SAY SOMETHING TO JIM DON'T
SAY THAT AGAIN. BUT IT DOESN'T
SEEM THAT RISES TO THE LEVEL OF
REPORTING AND FOR AN
INVESTIGATION.
BUT IF IT'S A SUPERVISOR WHO
SAYS IT TO APPEAR IN THAT COMES
ACROSS STATUS.
YOU NO HARASSMENT BECAUSE THE
SUPERIOR TO THE SUBORDINATE WHO
STARTING TO BE INTIMIDATING AND
SHE MAY NOT BE ABLE TO FEEL
COMFORTABLE TO REPORT. MY
SUPERVISORS MAKING INAPPROPRIATE
COMMENTS IN.
SO THAT'S THE DILEMMA I SEE FOR
ALL OF US IS DETERMINING THAT
CONTINUUM.
SO LOOKING AT WHAT YOU HAVE DONE
OVER THE YEARS YOU'VE BEEN IN
THE HOUSE.
SHARE WITH US.
WHERE YOU BEEN ABLE TO CHANGE
THE CULTURE BASED ON THE DATA
YOU'RE COLLECTING AND THAT WHAT
YOU'RE?
SHARING WITH US IS WORKING SOME
WAY SOMEHOW. WITH.
ODD THAT THE COMPANY CP STILL
CONSULT WITH YOU STARTED THE THE
CART BROUGHT YOU IN BECAUSE
THERE WERE ISSUES ARE THEY
WANTED TO AVOID ISSUES.
AND YOU PROVIDED THIS TRAINING
BOTH OF YOU IN YOUR SEPARATE.
DEMANDS AND SOMETHING'S WORKING
IN SOMETHING ISN'T BASED ON THE
FEEDBACK THAT YOU GOT WITH
THERE'S DATA COLLECTION. OR JUST
CONTINUING IN YOUR ROLE AS A
CONSULTANT.
BECAUSE WE'VE GOT TO MOVE THIS
PLACE SOMEWHERE IN THE NEXT
MONTH OR SO BECAUSE THERE'S MANY
INVESTIGATIONS THAT ARE STILL ON
GOING.
AND I'M NOT SURE HUNTING GETTING
THERE IN TERMS OF TELLING. THE
PEOPLE THAT SENT ME INTO THIS
COMMITTEE HERE'S WHAT WE NEED TO
DO AND I'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR
TWENTY YEARS I'VE HAD. THIS
TRAINING AS A LOCAL GOVERNMENT
OFFICIAL IS A STATE OFFICIAL IN
THE ASSEMBLY IN AND NOW HERE IN
THE SENATE.
WHAT IF I GAS THROUGH DISTURBING
US I THINK THE CULTURE OUTSIDE?
IN THE.
SOCIETY HAS CHANGED AND WE HAVE
MORE DON'T ASK PERMISSION ASK
FORGIVENESS IN WAIT TILL YOU'RE
CAUGHT.
BECAUSE OF THAT SEEMS TO BE THE
UNDERPINNING WE ARE SPECIFICALLY
TALKING ABOUT PERPETRATORS HERE.
WHO HAVE SAT THROUGH ALL OF THIS
WITH US OVER THE YEARS AND STILL
THINK A FULL CAVES TAKE THOSE
BABY STEPS?
I THOUGHT IN DOING SOMETHING
THAT BASICALLY STARTS TO GET TO
THE POINT OF PER.
OVER THE LINE A CRIMINAL SO HELP
ME UNDERSTAND.
IN YOUR TRAINING.
WHAT DO WE NEED TO TAKE OUT OF
THESE?
AND USE IN TERMS OF WHERE YOU'VE
BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL IN
COMPANIES COLLEGE YOU FORWARD.
TO HELP THEM.
THEY'RE ALL A BIG ASK BUT HE.
HOOKED IN JUST A FEW MONTHS OR
WEEKS WE'RE GOING TO BE ASKED
BACK. NO QUESTION WELL I THINK
THERE'S A COUPLE THINGS.
YEAH. THE ISSUE OF OF THAT
HARASSMENT.
IN ANY FORM. IS SYSTEMIC IN YOUR
WORKPLACE WOULD HAVE TO START
WITH YOUR CULTURE.
IT HOUSE TO BE WHERE PEOPLE ARE
NO LONGER ACCEPTING THAT
BEHAVIOR AT ALL LEVELS.
SO IN THE ORGANIZATIONS I WORK
WITH THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE REALIZADA OF WE COME IN
THERE FROM A VERY LEGALISTIC
THOU SHALT NOT TYPE OF TRAINING.
NO ONE'S LISTENING AND THEY DO
EXACTLY WHAT YOU'VE ALL
EXPERIENCE THEY GO TO THE TO OUR
TRAINING THEY GO OUT THEY GO SH.
I COULD'VE BEEN DOING EMAIL YOU
KNOW AND THEY DON'T THINK
ANYTHING ABOUT IT AFTER THE
FACT.
WHEN WE APPROACH IT IN A
DIFFERENT WAY OF SAYING LOOK WE
GET IT YOU'RE HUMAN.
BUT SO ARE THE PEOPLE AROUND YOU
AND YOU HAVE TO RESPECT THEIR
SPACE IF WE DON'T. GO IN AND SAY
WE'RE DOING HARASSMENT
PREVENTION TRAINING WE GO IN AND
SAY WE'RE DOING RESPECT IN THE
WORKPLACE TRAINING.
AND IT CHANGES THE MIND SET FROM
THE VERY BEGINNING.
AND WE TALK ABOUT ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
IN THE YOU BEEN TALKING ABOUT
FOR WEEKS AND MONTHS.
AND. IT COMES DOWN TO THIS.
NOW THE SENIOR MANAGERS CEOS
EXECUTIVES ARE TAKING THIS MORE
SERIOUSLY AND UNFORTUNATELY IT
DID HAVE TO HAPPEN WITH ALL THE
NEWS THAT WE'VE SEEN LATELY THAT
NOW THEY'RE STARTING TO. TAKE
NOTICE.
THEY HAD TO COME TO THAT FOR
THEM TO MAKE THE CHANGE BECAUSE
UNTIL THEY MAKE THE CHANGE.
NOBODY ELSE IN THEIR
ORGANIZATION.
SO.
FOR YOUR LEVEL YOU THAT YOUR
LEADERS HAVE TO TAKE THAT CHANGE
THE INTERNS.
YOU'RE RIGHT IF AN INTERN SAYS
SOMETHING LIKE THAT TO ANOTHER
INTERN IT'S REALLY NOT THE SAME
THING BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
POWER OVER EACH OTHER.
BUT THAT SENATOR FOR THAT IS HOW
WE PERSON ABSOLUTELY CAN DESTROY
THEIR CAREER.
AND IT'S THE SAME IN THE
WORKPLACE
IF I'M A RECEPTIONIST AND THE
CEO SAID SOMETHING.
AND INAPPROPRIATE TO ME. YEAH
I'M PROBABLY GONNA SAY QUIET
BECAUSE I'M JUST STARTING IN THE
WORKPLACE AND I NEED A JOB.
AND THAT'S JUST DOES THE FACTS
BUT I THINK WE'RE SEEING A SEA
CHANGE NOW BECAUSE OF EVERYTHING
IN THE NEWS AND AND IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THAT IT HAD TO
HAPPEN THAT WAY.
BUT IF THAT'S WHAT IT TOOK TO TO
MAKE SOCIETY CHANGE. YEAH AND I
THINK A SOCIETY CHANGES WE'RE
GONNA HOLD EVERYBODY ELSE MARK
COUNTABLE.
IF HAVE IN THE COMPANY'S YOU
WORK WITH IS THE FEEDBACK THAT
WOULD THE TRAINING YOU GIVEN.
HAVE HELPED DRAMATICALLY. IT'S
HOPE FROM THE FOR A LOT OF THE
FEEDBACK THAT I GET FROM MY
CLIENTS IS.
FIRST OF ALL THAT'S THE BEST
TRAINING THEY'VE EVER HAD THAT'S
NOT ABOUT ME THEY JUST LIKE THE
APPROACH BETTER THAT IT'S NOT.
HARSH.
AND THE SECOND PIECE IS. THAT
WE'RE NOT POINTING FINGERS AT
ANYBODY NOPE WE DON'T. APPROACH
AT THE YOUR HORRIBLE PERSON HOW
DARE YOU. OF ALL THAT COULD BE
SOME OUT THERE BUT. WE APPROACH
IT FROM A SENSE OF LUCK YOU NEED
TO BE AWARE NEED TO MAKE THOSE
CHANGES AND HERE'S WHY HERE'S
HOW IT HELPS YOUR PRODUCTIVITY
IN YOUR. BOTTOM LINE IN YOUR
COMPANY AND.
YOU KNOW IT. NOBODY EVER WANTS
TO COME TO WORK.
AND FEEL LIKE OH MY GOD I HAVE
TO WORK WITH THAT PERSON AGAIN
TODAY.
AND NO COMPANY WANTS TO LOSE
THEIR BEST TALENT BECAUSE THIS
PERVASIVE IN THEIR ORGANIZATION.
BUT THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS PEOPLE
WILL LEAVE.
SO YOU KNOW I'VE DONE I'M SURE
PATTY IS IN THE SAME THING WE'VE
SEEN MANY PEOPLE LOSE GREAT
TALENT.
BECAUSE THAT ONE PERSON WHO THEY
JUST COULDN'T DO WITHOUT.
IS STILL THERE AND SO THEY LOSE
TWENTY FIVE OF THEIR BEST
PEOPLE.
AND EVENTUALLY PEOPLE GO ON ALL
THE SOCIAL MEDIA THEY SAY DON'T
WORK FOR THAT COMPANY BECAUSE
THAT'S WHERE KATHY WORKS AND
SHE'S A HORRIBLE BOSS. AND
HERE'S WHAT SHE DOES.
AND THAT IS IT GOES ALL THE WAY
DOWN THE LINE AND THAT COULD BE
IN YOUR ORGANIZATION TO DON'T
WORK FOR THAT SENATOR. AND
HERE'S WHY.
SO I'VE GOTTEN MUCH MORE TO SAY
ON TRAINING EXCEPT.
TO REITERATE THE POINT THE
TRAINING HAS TO BE A PIECE OF
THE PUZZLE. NOT THE PUZZLE
ITSELF AND SO IT IT'S JUST NOT
GOING TO BE EFFECTIVE IF IT'S
TODD.
A SMALL PART OF A MUCH MORE
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN SO WITH THAT
IN MIND VERY VISUAL AND SO FOR
ME ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
THINK IS. HELPFUL TO VISUALIZE
WHEN YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT AN
OVERHAUL. IS PRE REPORT AND POST
REPORT.
SO PREBOR PORT TO ME IS WHERE
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO BE
DONE.
AS THE STATISTICS THAT I SHARED
SHOW THE VAST MAJORITY OF
COMPLAINTS START EVERITT
REPORTED THEY NEVER GET TO A
POINT WHERE WE WERE GIVEN AN
OPPORTUNITY. NOW IN SOME CASES
THAT'S OKAY IT'S BECAUSE. THAT
WE ARE HOPEFULLY EMPOWERING
PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO SOLVE
PROBLEMS ON THE ROAD AND THAT'S
A REALLY IMPORTANT COMPONENT.
DOTS WERE TOOLS LIKE A WORKPLACE
COLOR SPECTRUM THAT'S FOR TOOLS
LIKE COMMUNICATION SKILLS I
THINK IT REALLY GOAL LONG WAY
TOWARDS HELPING TO DIFFUSE
SITUATIONS VERY EARLY. SO THERE
ARE WAYS THAT I THINK.
YOU CAN VERY EFFECTIVELY CREATE
A CULTURE OF TRUTH TELLING NOT
ONLY IN TERMS OF TELLING THE
TRUTH IN A FORMAL REPORT. BUT
BEING TRUTHFUL WITH EACH OTHER
BEING SUPPORTIVE OF EACH OTHER
AND HAVING A CULTURE WHERE NOT
ONLY THE VICTIM SPEAKS UP BUT
THE.
BYSTANDER SPEAK UP AND AND THEN
A KEY COMPONENT IS WHERE THE
PERSON ACCUSED IS MATURE ENOUGH
TO SAY. YOU KNOW WHAT. I'M SORRY
THAT'S NOT WHAT I MEANT AND I'M
GONNA LEARN FROM IT.
SO THAT'S SORT OF THE PRE REPORT
THE POST REPORT YOU KNOW I'VE
COME UP WITH A REALLY SIMPLE
THREE STEP PROCESS OF YOU DO
RECEIVE A REPORT. YOU TAKE IT
SERIOUSLY YOU INVESTIGATE IT
WELL AND YOU FIX THE PROBLEM.
I'VE SEEN TO MANY INSTANCES
WHERE SOMEBODY COMES TO.
THAT THE APPROPRIATE AUTHORITY
IF YOU WILL AND SAYS YOU KNOW I
HAVE SOMETHING TO REPORT.
AND THE REACTION IS WELL THAT'S
JUST BOB YOU KNOW THAT'S JUST
WHAT BOB IS. SO TAKING IT
SERIOUSLY OF THE VERY FIRST STEP
THE NEXT IS PERFORMING A REALLY
THOROUGH AND FAIR INVESTIGATION.
BUT WHERE I SEE.
.
THE BIGGEST ISSUES IS ON THE
THIRD STEP WHICH IS FIXING IT.
SO THE HIGH VALUE EMPLOYEE ISSUE
COMES AND A VERY PRACTICAL TOOL
THAT I'VE AND PROVIDE ITS MIKE
TWO THINGS THAT PROVIDE TO MY
CLIENTS ONE IS.
PUT THE BEHAVIOR BEFORE YOU EVEN
START THINKING ABOUT WHAT YOUR
SOLUTION IS GOING TO BE. IN A
RANGE
SO IF IT'S ON A SCALE OF ONE TO
TEN IS THE MISCONDUCT THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A ONE OR TWO.
RISEN IN EIGHT OR NINE BECAUSE
THAT'S REALLY GOING TO INFORM
WHAT IS THAT YOU'RE GONNA DO IS
THIS SOMETHING THAT'S POSSIBLY A
TERMINATION INTERMINABLE
OFFENSE.
OR ARE WE TALKING ABOUT TWO
INTERNS WHO BAPTISM YOU DO
NOTHING BUT IT MEANS THAT YOUR
ULTIMATE REMEDY IS GOING TO BE A
VERY DIFFERENT THING THAN IF THE
BEHAVIOR IS MUCH MORE CREATURES.
TAKE OTHER FACTORS INTO
CONSIDERATION IS THIS THE FIRST
TIME OR IS IT THE TWENTIETH TIME
THAT THIS PERSON HAS ENGAGED IN
THIS TYPE OF CONDUCT. AND ALL
THAT WHAT I THE FREEZE THAT I
THAT I CLEAN FOR MY CLIENTS AS I
WOULD GIVE THEM WHEN I CALLED
MYSELF WHICH ABILITY SCALE.
SO ARE BY SALVAGEABLE HE READING
OUT SO AFTER I SPOKE TO THE
PERSON ACCUSED OF MISCONDUCT.
I WOULD HAVE A PRETTY GOOD READ
ON IS THIS PERSON UNDERSTANDING.
.
THE SEVERITY OF THE BEHAVIOR
THAT THEY ENGAGE CENTER THEY
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR IT ARE
THE STUFF AWARE ENOUGH. TO
REALLY BE WILLING TO MAKE SOME
CHANGES UP OF COURSE IN THE IN
THE CASES WHERE I FOUND THAT
THERE WAS SOME LEVEL OF
MISCONDUCT.
SO THAT'S THE PART WHERE I THINK
WE REALLY NEED TO BE.
METICULOUS ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THERE IS A RANGE AND A PERSON
WHO IS YOU KNOW ACCUSED EVER
FOUND TO ENGAGE IN MISCONDUCT
THAT'S A ONE. IS NOT GONNA
RECEIVE A DISCIPLINARY MEASURE
THAT'S A TEN. AND CONVERSELY
SOMEONE WHO IS FOUND TO ENGAGE
AN EGREGIOUS BEHAVIOR SHOULDN'T
GET A ONE.
THE FINAL THING I'LL SAY ON THAT
WHERE I THINK ENTITIES IN
GENERAL WHETHER PUBLIC OR
PRIVATE.
I REALLY HAVE BEEN HIS
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE DOES
SEEM TO BE THIS IDEA THAT YOU
EITHER DO NOTHING. OR YOU FIRE
SOMEONE.
THERE A MILLION THINGS IN
BETWEEN THAT CAN BE DONE THAT
ARE EFFECTIVE AND PART OF THAT
SALVAGEABLE THE READING THAT I
WOULD GIVE TO MY CLIENTS WOULD
BE. HERE'S WHAT I FOUND OUT
ABOUT FOR A DURING MY INTERVIEW
HE IS MOTIVATED ALMOST SOLELY BY
PRESTIGE AND MONEY. AND SO YOU
STANDING UP TO ONE HOUR TRAINING
SESSION IS GOING TO DO NOTHING.
YOU DEMOTING HIM. YOU TAKING HIS
BONUS AWAY YOU TAKING AWAY A
CHAIRMANSHIP BORROWER OR SOME
OTHER IMPORTANT POSITION NOW
THAT'S GOING TO SEND A MESSAGE.
AND SO I THINK REALLY BEING
METICULOUS ABOUT HOW IT IS THAT
WE APPROACH NOT JUST. THE
RECEIVING OF COMPLAINTS IN THE
INVESTIGATING OF COMPLAINTS BUT
RESOLVING THEM.
THE KEY THAT HELPS A LOT IN
TERMS OF THE.
THE CONTINUE OF CONSEQUENCE
BRITAIN WHETHER THAT STARTS TO
CHANGE THE CULTURE KNOWING THAT
YOU IF YOU ARE THE PERPETRATOR.
YOU KNOW HERE'S HERE'S THE AYE
DASHBOARD MOTHER TO SPEAK OF
THANK YOU.
THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FOR
THE PANEL.
SENATOR MITCHELL DIDN'T.
GLAD I MADE IT BACK BUT TO HEAR
SENATOR BATES QUESTION WITH
REGARD TO CULTURE.
AND I IN HEARING YOU ARTICULATE
YOUR QUESTION.
SENATOR BATES SAID IT I REALIZED
THAT.
LONELY START THIS PROCESS.
I HAD A GENERAL IDEA OF WHAT I
THOUGHT THE INSTITUTION SHOULD
DO.
THROUGH THE HEARING PROCESS AS
FAR AYE THEN MOVED TO A PLACE OF
OVERWHELM BASED ON ALL THE
INFORMATION WE ARE RECEIVING.
.
AND I FEEL THAT I'VE COME FULL
CIRCLE.
TO A PLACE WHERE.
IF WE. THIS COMMITTEE IS GOING
TO HAVE THE COLLECTIVE COURAGE
TO MAKE A RECOMMENDATION TO THE
JOINT RULES.
ACKNOWLEDGING A NEED FOR CULTURE
CHANGE THAT WE HAVE TO PROPOSED
RADICAL CHANGE.
AND IN HEARING THE EXAMPLES
TODAY ABOUT TRAINING THAT WORKS.
AND HOW DIFFERENT IT IS FROM THE
TRAINING WE EXPERIENCE.
I HAVE EVERY CONFIDENCE THAT IF
WE.
LOOK AT CULTURE LOOK AT
TRAINING.
AND REALLY HAVE A HOLISTIC VIEW
OF OF IT BECAUSE EVERYTHING THAT
BUT WE HAVE LEARNED IN THESE
FIVE HEARINGS HAVE BEEN
CONSISTENT. IF WE CHOOSE TO DO
SOME DIFFERENT IT WILL BE ON US
NOT BECAUSE THE MESSAGES WE
SEEMED WERE NOT CONSISTENT. IN
TERMS OF WHAT RESEARCH AND WHAT
PRACTICE.
IS TELLING US WHAT WORK AND SO
IT'S GOING TO BE UP TO US TO
REALLY DECIDE TO RECOMMEND
RADICAL CHANGE.
YOU KNOW THE FACT THAT WE DO
HAVE WITH THE TWO NAMES AT THE
WATER COOLER.
JANE IN FRED WITHOUT ALL THIS
WHOEVER THIS YOU KNOW THE REAL A
THING THAT OFTEN BECAUSE THEY
WERE THE REAL NAMES SUITED YOU
SEVEN I REMEMBER IT LIKE. THE
RIDICULOUSLY LAME EXAMPLE IN OUR
TRAINING AND IT'S NOT GERMANE TO
WHAT WE DO. AND AND WHILE WE
SPEND SO MUCH TIME IN THESE
HEARINGS TALK ABOUT YOU WILL
WERE DIFFERENT BLOW OVER
DIFFERENT. AND WE ARE AND
THEREFORE OUR TRAINING SHOULD
REFLECT THAT
NOW WE HAVE THE POWER THROUGH TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN SOUGHT THANK
YOU FOR THAT BECAUSE IT. TOOK ME
ON MY FULL CIRCLE LIKE WE HAVE
TO STEP UP IF WE WANT MEASURABLE
CHANGE IN OUR CULTURE THEN WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO.
PUSH THE ENVELOPE TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN REALLY.
MISS PEREIRA'S BOMBING. TELL ME
WHAT MICRO LEARNING IS I'VE I
HAVE AN ASSUMPTION BUT OUT OF
ONE ASSUME FLOPPY THROUGH DEFINE
THAT FOR ME. YOU REFERENCE THAT
MY YOUR SLIDES YEAH IT IT'S JUST
WHAT IT SOUNDS LIKE SO YOU'VE
GOT SORT OF YOUR FORMAL TRAINING
WHICH. CAN BE DONE IN IN ONE
SITTING OR AS WAS SUGGESTED
EARLIER COULD BE DONE YOU KNOW
THAT THE TWO HOUR LET'S SAY
REQUIRE TRAINING. THE MICRO
LEARNING.
BURSTS WE CALL THEM IS IT A WAY
OF STRENGTHENING OF REINFORCING
OF GIVING A DIFFERENT POINT OF
VIEW SO GIVE YOU A COUPLE OF THE
ACTUAL EXAMPLES SO WE HAVE OUR
OUR HARASSMENT TRAINING
PERMITTING WORKPLACE HARASSMENT
TRAINING WE HAVE OUR UNCONSCIOUS
BIAS TRAINING WE HAVE THAT.
SUITE OF FIVE ESSENTIALS THAT I
FOR A REFERENCE TO A NUMBER OF
TIMES BUT THEN WE HAVE THESE
MICRO LEARNING LESSONS THAT ARE.
THE VIDEOS THAT I REFERENCED
EARLIER SO IT'S A VIDEO ON WHAT
TO DO IF YOU'RE A BYSTANDER AND
IT COMES NOT JUST WITH A VIDEO
BUT WITH THE MANY LEARNING
LESSON THAT SAYS.
HERE WAYS IN WHICH YOU CAN
INTERVENE MAYBE A COUPLE OF
POLLING QUESTIONS AND ASK YOU
ABOUT IT. ANOTHER ONE THAT I'VE
REFERENCED ALREADY IS A GUIDE
THAT I HAVE FOUR PEOPLE WERE
TARGETS AND SO IN ADDITION TO
THE VIDEO THERE'S ACTUALLY HAND
OUT THAT SAYS. HERE'S THREE
DIFFERENT WAYS THAT YOU MIGHT BE
ABLE TO SAY TO SOMEBODY IF YOU
FIND YOURSELF IN A POSITION.
WHERE YOU'RE BEING EXPOSED TO
SOME TYPE OF BEHAVIOR ABOUT WHAT
WE FOUND IS THAT PEOPLE
OFTENTIMES JUST DON'T KNOW WHAT
TO SAY OR HOW TO SAY IT? AND SO
THIS IS A SCRIPT THAT SAYS IF
YOU'RE COMFORTABLE DEALING WITH
IT YOURSELF HERE SOME EXAMPLES
OF THE WAYS YOU CAN DEAL WITH
IT.
IF YOU'RE NOT AND YOU GO TO HR
HERE'S A SCRIPT FOR WHAT TO SAY
OR NOT SAY SO THAT'S ANOTHER
MICRO LEARNING LESSON IS A WAY.
OF AGAIN JUST REINFORCING WHAT'S
BEEN DONE SO AT LEAST FROM OUR
VIEW THOUGH THEY HAVE TO BE.
RELEVANT AND AGAIN ALL SORT OF
POINT TO NOT ONLY WORKPLACE
CULTURE BUT.
THESE FIVE LESSONS TO TO
COINCIDE WITH AND REALLY
REINFORCE THOSE THINGS. THAT WE
THOUGHT IT WAS.
IT IT WAS BUT I WANT TO BE SURE.
BECAUSE AS I SHARED WITH WITH
MADAM CHAIR AS I'M LISTENING TO
YOU AND HEARING.
ABOUT ABOUT FRAMING.
THAT YOU DON'T FRAME AS IF
YOU'RE COMING TO HEAR THAT YOU
KNOW TO LEARN THE LAW. AND
RECOGNIZING THAT THERE ARE KIND
OF.
.
ORGANICS THE WRONG WORD BUT BUT
BOTH CAUCUSES IN BOTH HOUSES
HAVE. WEEKLY CAUCUSES.
IT'S A PART OF OUR CULTURE OUR
EXISTING CULTURE WHERE WE GO
WITH MEMBERS TO RECEIVE
INFORMATION LEARN NEW
INFORMATION EXCHANGE
INFORMATION.
AND SO I WANTED TO KNOW WHAT THE
MICRO LEARNING PIECE WAS BECAUSE
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT. IN ADDITION
TO OUR ONCE A YEAR ARE MANDATED
WE CAN USE THESE EXISTING
OPPORTUNITIES.
ONCE A MONTH ONCE EVERY OTHER
MONTH.
TWO HAVE THE MICRO LEARNING
EXPERIENCE AROUND CULTURE.
THAT IT'S NOT A SEPARATE
SCHEDULE TIME WHERE WE.
YOU KNOW IT IF CAUCUSES ON
EVERYONE'S CALENDAR IN BOTH
HOUSES EVERY WEEK.
AND SO FIGURED OUT WAYS IN WHICH
WE CAN INTEGRATE.
LEARNING. NEW WAYS OF THINKING
INTO OUR EXISTING KIND OF
PATTERN AND PRACTICE.
MAY BE HELPFUL SLEPT WELL AND
UNDERSTAND WHAT WHAT WHAT
MICHAEL LEARNING WHAT TO SEE IF
THAT MADE SENSE AND IF I COULD
JUST ADD ONE THING BECAUSE I
THINK THAT'S A FABULOUS IDEA.
ANOTHER.
VERY PRACTICAL WAY IN WHICH I
FOUND.
THIS THIS WORKS WELL AND I
CERTAINLY INCORPORATED INTO MY
MY TRAINING IS USING EITHER REAL
LIFE EXAMPLES OR IN MY CASE I
CAN USE REAL LIFE EXAMPLES
BECAUSE I'VE DONE SO MANY
INVESTIGATIONS AND NO ONE KNOWS
WHERE THEY'RE FROM. BUT I'LL
GIVE YOU REALLY QUICK ONE I HAVE
A AN INVESTIGATION I CONDUCTED
WHERE A SUPERVISOR SAID TO HIS
YOUNG AS.
ASSISTANT HEY MY FLIES OPEN
WHAT YOU TELL ME MY FLY WAS OPEN
HE SAID IT TWICE.
I STOPPED THERE AND I GET A
WILL SAY TO THE PEOPLE ON TRAIN
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT. AND
ONE OF THE MOST INTERESTING
THINGS IS IT REALLY STARTS A
CONVERSATION WHICH IS REALLY THE
MAIN POINT I WANT TO MAKE ABOUT
THIS MICRO LEARNING LESSON IS IT
STARTS PEOPLE IN A VERY
COMFORTABLE WAY TALKING ABOUT
IT.
PEERS Y. THIS PARTICULAR
HYPOTHETIC OR NOT HYPOTHETICAL
FACT PATTERN IS IS REALLY
INTERESTING.
WHAT I SAY I STOP THERE AND GET
MORE FACTS AND I SAY WHAT DO YOU
GUYS THINK IT'S INAPPROPRIATE
CONDUCT IS THAT YOU KNOW MAYBE
RISING TO UP MORE THAN JUST AN
APPROPRIATE?
%
IT'S PRETTY UNIVERSAL THAT WOMEN
WILL SAY TO ME THAT'S GROSS AND
I DON'T WANT MY BOSS TELLING ME
TO YOU KNOW LOOK AT THAT PART OF
HIS BODY. AND I'VE HAD A SMALL
PERCENTAGE BUT A PERCENTAGE OF
MEN WHO WILL SAY TO ME WELL
BEFORE I CAN TELL YOU IT'S
APPROPRIATE OR NOT. I NEED TO
KNOW IF HIS FLIGHT WAS REALLY
DOWN.
BECAUSE IF IT WASN'T DOWN THEN
HE'S A CREEP BUT IT WAS DOWN
THEN MAYBE WAS JUST LEGITIMATELY
TRYING TO I'VE NEVER HAD A WOMAN
SAY THAT TO ME. SO I USE THIS
HYPOTHETICAL ON WHERE THE STOCK
PATTERN ON PURPOSE TO REALLY
START HIGHLIGHTING THAT YOU KNOW
WE SEE THE WORLD DIFFERENTLY.
AND SO IT IT REALLY.
NOW IS A ROBUST AND HONEST
DISCUSSION AGAIN NOT BLAMING NOT
SAYING YOU'RE A BAD GUY YOU'RE A
GOOD GUY BUT STARTING THIS
CONVERSATION I THEN MOVE ON TO
GIVE A LITTLE BIT MORE FACTS AND
WITHOUT. GOING INTO THE INTO IT
TOO DEEPLY IT TURNS OUT THAT THE
THE GENTLEMAN WHO ENGAGE IN THE
BEHAVIOR WAS ABOUT THIRTY YEARS
OLDER THAN THE YOUNG LADY AND
TALKED CONSTANTLY. ABOUT HOW HIS
PREFERRED DEMOGRAPHIC WAS
EXACTLY THIS YOUNG LADY AND SO
IT PUTS THINGS IN CONTEXT NOW
SUDDENLY IT'S NOT JUST HIM
SAYING OF MY FLY OPEN. IT IS HER
SAYING.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE'S HITTING ON
ME BUT I SURE KNOW THAT OUR
PHONE TWO WAS DEMOGRAPHIC
BECAUSE YOU KNOW HE TALKS ALL
THE TIME NOT ABOUT SEX. BUT
ABOUT LIKING WOMEN MY AGE SO
MAYBE MAYBE HE'S OUT THERE
FISHING FOR IT. AND NOW SUDDENLY
THE PEOPLE IN THE TRAINING
SESSION OR LIKE ALL THAT'S ALL
DIFFERENT ONCE YOU PUT IT INTO
CONTEXT SO THAT'S ANOTHER
MICHAEL LEARNING LESSON IT'S A
TEN MINUTE CONVERSATION. BUT IT
OPENS UP A DISCUSSION THAT
REALLY IN A WAY THAT'S NOT
BLAMING IN A WAY THAT'S NOT.
DEFENSIVE.
PEOPLE WALK OUT OF THERE SAYING
HE I GUESS MAYBE I SEE THE WORLD
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENTLY AND
CONTEXT REALLY MATTERS.
AND IT DOES MATTER AND AND THE
EXAMPLES YOU'VE GIVEN LET US
KNOW THAT SO MUCH OF OUR LIVES
ARE IN THE GRAY AREA. AS OPPOSED
TO THE REALLY KIND OF SIMPLISTIC
CAN I FILL GIVE COPS.
DOUBLE THE COMPLIMENTS WERE
PERFECT BECAUSE THEY'RE VERY
DIFFERENT
AS MY FATHER WOULD SAY STEVIE
WONDER COULD SEE THE DIFFERENCE
IN THOSE TO HOW THEY WERE
DIFFERENT.
FOR ME MADAM CHAIR.
IN THE HANDOUT YOU SHARE WITH US
YOU TALKED ABOUT.
BUT. A ON PAGE. FOUR OF THE
HANDOUTS THAT THREE SLIDES ON
RETALIATION.
TALL MEN AND WE'VE HAD LOTS OF
CONVERSATION PREVIOUS HEARINGS
ARE RETALIATION.
AND. THE THIRD SLIDE.
YOU SAY HOW CAN WE PREVENT
RETALIATION AND YOUR LAST BULLET
THIS DOCUMENT DOCUMENT DOCUMENT.
CAN YOU EXPAND UPON THAT BELIEF.
SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
RETALIATION AND DISLIKE
PARTICULARLY THAT THE END ARE
YOU ASKING THAT SPECIFICALLY
THAT LINE DOCUMENT DOCUMENT ON.
JUSTICE SIX BY IF LONG EACH OUR
MANTRA THAT WE ARE IS A
DOCUMENTED RIGHT RIGHT.
BUT YEAH THERE THERE IS A.
PART WHERE WE'D DOCUMENT THESE
THINGS EVEN IF THEY'RE JUST.
KIND OF MAYBE NOT A FULL
HARASSMENT NOT REALLY SOMETHING
PERVASIVE VIA.
BUT WE DOCUMENTED IN THE SENSE
THAT IF IT HAPPENS AGAIN ARE WE
NOW SEEING A PATTERN.
IF THIS PERSON IN NO IS AS PRICE
THAT EARLIER TWENTY ONE TIMES IS
DOING THIS THAT'S A LOT
DIFFERENT THAN THE PERSON WHO'S
DONE IT ONCE.
AND SO WHEN WE'RE GOING BACK AND
WE'RE SAYING WELL YOU KNOW YEAH
HE'S A KEY EMPLOYEES BUT HE DOES
THIS EVERY MONDAY.
YOU KNOW WHEN THE STAFF COMES IN
WITH YOU KNOW COFFEE OR
WHATEVER.
AND THE DOCUMENTATION FOR
RETALIATION IS. LOOK WE'VE
WARNED YOU RETALIATION IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE SO IF WE HAVE DONE AN
INVESTIGATION OR EVEN IF WE'VE
JUST HAD THAT INITIAL
CONVERSATION SAYING LOOK YOUR
YOUR COMMENTS WERE
INAPPROPRIATE.
AND A BRIGHT THEY WERE
DEPRECIATED SO YOU KNOW WERE
COUNSELING YOU NOW TO PLEASE
STOP THAT.
AND YOU CANNOT GO BACK INTO
THAT.
AREA AND NOW HARASS THE PERSON
WHO JUST REPORTED THIS.
NO BECAUSE THEY FELT
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH YOUR WORDS.
THAT'S WHY WE DOCUMENT SO IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO HAVE A
RECORD OF THAT BECAUSE YOU KNOW
IN THE WORKPLACE.
THESE THINGS HAPPEN ALL THE TIME
AND IF THEY'RE NOT DOCUMENTED
IT'S YOUR WORD AGAINST THEIRS.
AND SO THAT'S IN TERMS OF THE HR
PROFESSIONALS ROLE COULD YOU
TALK ABOUT EXPECTATIONS AROUND.
PRETTY SUPERVISORS AND OTHERS
DOCUMENT I HAD AN HR.
PER PROFESSIONAL WHO TAUGHT ME
HOW TO WRITE MEMOS TO FILE A AS
A YOUNG SUPERVISOR.
THAT THAT WAR YOU KNOW I DIDN'T
RECEIVE THEM AS OFFICIAL
DOCUMENTATION BUT IF I SAW A
PATTERN THAT I THEN DECIDED I
NEED TO GO TO HR. IKE IT DIDN'T
REFRESH MY OWN MEMORY TERMS OF
DETAILS DATE SPECIFICS IN TERMS
OF.
YOU KNOW THE LITTLE PEBBLES
EARLY ON THAT THE AND.
LOOKED AT.
COMPREHENSIVELY COULD. PROPOSE A
PROBLEM SO.
DOCUMENTING.
LET OTHER LEVELS WITHIN THE
ORGANIZATION TIGHTLY SO WHEN
WE'RE COACHING MANAGEMENT.
YOU KNOW HOW TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE STUFF IN THE REAL WORLD.
WE DO TELL THEM YOU KNOW YOU
THESE ARE THE THINGS YOU WANT TO
MAKE A NOTE OF. AND AND MAYBE
THEY'RE NOT A FORMAL RIGHT UP AT
THIS POINT THEY'RE JUST YOU KNOW
YOU SAID IT MOMENTO FILE KIND OF
THING. BUT IT IS MORE TO THE
POINT OF SAYING IF MY EMPLOYEE
CAME AND TOLD ME THIS.
THEN I'M GOING TO TAKE NOTE OF
IT.
AND I'M AND I'M GOING TO
DOCUMENT THAT I HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH THIS PERSON
BECAUSE WHY WOULDN'T YOU.
AND THEY ARE GOING TO FIX THE
PROBLEM IF YOU CAN THEN MAYBE IT
DOES ESCALATE TO HR AT SOME
POINT AND THEN YOU HAVE YOUR
DOCUMENTATION PLACING THE LOOK
THAT I'VE BEEN WATCHING THIS FOR
A WEEK. OR TWO OR A MONTH AND
THIS IS WHAT I HAVE SEEN AND I
THINK THERE DEFINITELY IS A
PROBLEM.
ALL OF THOSE THINGS ARE HELPFUL
BUT AS A YOU KNOW IF YOU ALL
KNOW THEY'RE ALSO DISCOVERABLE
SO.
THIS IS THIS IS NOT A.
YOU KNOW SOMETHING THAT WE
WOULD DISCOURAGE AT ALL BECAUSE
WE WANT THAT DOCUMENTATION
MOSTLY BECAUSE PEOPLE'S MEMORIES
GET FUZZY.
SO IT'S IMPORTANT HAVE THAT TIME
STAMP IN THOSE ACCURATE NOTES
YOU KNOW FOR ANYTHING THAT GOES
FORWARD THE EVERYTHING IS.
WE DON'T EVER WANT MANAGERS TO
DO INVESTIGATIONS. THEY'RE NOT
EQUIPPED TO DO SO. SO THEIR
NOTES ARE IMPORTANT FOR A CHARGE
YOU RECEIVE OR FOR COUNSEL TO
RECEIVE SO THAT THEY CAN PURSUE
WITH AN ACTUAL INVESTIGATION.
THE DOCUMENTATION IS IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM.
THANK YOU ANY LAST QUESTIONS FOR
THIS PANEL. EQUIPMENT THANK YOU
BOTH VERY MUCH TRULY APPRECIATE
YOUR INSIGHT AND YOUR TAKING THE
TIME TO COME AND SEE US TODAY.
THANK YOU PROVIDING A SECURE
WITHOUT WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENTS IF THERE'S ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC WHO WISHES
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. NASHER
CHANCE IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND
COMING UP TO THE MICROPHONE.
ANYBODY.
OKAY SEEN NOT OTHERS REMIND
ANYBODY WATCHING OR IN THE ROOM
THAT WE DO HAVE A SUGGESTION BOX
WE HAVE WAYS OF.
SENDING COMMENTS TO US ONLINE
AS WELL.
COME ON YOU CAN ALSO ALWAYS COME
TO SPEAK TO SPEAK TO MYSELF OR
TO THE VICE CHAIR.
IF YOU HAVE ANYTHING SPECIFIC
YOU WANT TO RELATE US.
AND WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
ON ENDING THIS COMMITTEE AND
JUST TO REMIND EVERYBODY WE ARE
WAITING POINT B. WAITING FOR THE
RESULTS OF THE CULTURE SURVEY TO
COME BACK.
THAT WE WILL BE.
OF MEETING ONE MORE TIME EITHER
WITH THIS COMMITTEE OR WITH THE
JOINT RULES TO MAKE OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THEY WILL BE
TANGIBLE AND CONCRETE AND I I DO
BELIEVE OF GROUND UP.
CHANGE OF OUR POLICIES ARE
TRAINING AND ALL WITH AN
ATTEMPTED CHANGE OUR CULTURE TO
BE. MUCH MORE PROTECTIVE AND
MUCH MORE RESPECTFUL OF ALL OF
OUR EMPLOYEES SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR PARTICIPATING MUMBLED
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE